good morning everyone and welcome to the
tuesday february 8th meeting of the
science technology and energy committee
we have
five public hearings that we will
conduct during the course of today
obviously with the
traffic accident on
interstate 93
folks are going to be filing in slowly
over the course of the
next uh several minutes
and
unfortunately we're gonna have to go
ahead and get started
both to
be respectful of people who showed up
here to testify this morning and also to
continue
to
operate the committee in an efficient
manner but before i call on the
opening speaker our very first duty this
morning
is to all rise and join together as
representative bernardi leads us in the
pledge of allegiance
okay so before we get begin a couple of
housekeeping measures if you would like
to testify on this or any other bill
before the committee today
you must fill out and submit a pink card
and pass it along
the table
so that it reaches
myself and the clerk
that's how we
keep track of who wants to testify
on a bill
also it's been pointed out to me by
representative thomas that if there is
anyone here who is hard of hearing
there is a
uh microphone jack on the side of these
microphones that we all have sitting in
front of us and if you have headphones
you could plug in to the microphone jack
and listen to testimony that way rather
than having to rely on the testimony
coming through the speakers
i didn't realize that but representative
thomas pointed that out this morning so
that's something you can take advantage
of if you so desire
and uh
with that oh one other thing that i
would remind committee members about
yesterday we conducted an exec session
on five bills there were
minority reports assigned if you have
been assigned a minority report i need
that report by 5 pm
today
so with that i will open the public
hearing on house bill
1596 fn relative to net
energy metering limits for individual
and business customers
and i will turn the floor over to the
bill's prime sponsor
representative rebecca mcwilliams
thank you chairvoz it's a pleasure to be
here fellow members of science
technology and energy for the record my
name is representative rebecca
mcwilliams
i represent the west side of concord
i'm here today to talk about raising net
energy
metering limits from one to five
megawatts
and i know we've had robust discussions
about this in the past i just want to
touch on a couple of points of history
on this specific topic
when i joined science technology and
energy
four years ago
we were able to come to a bipartisan
consensus on passing increases in net
net energy metering from one to five
megawatts here in the house
we were also able to pass it out the
other body
it was then subsequently vetoed by our
governor
and we had an override session to try to
override that specific bill
and we were awful close to being able to
do that we almost got our two-thirds
majority so there was definitely a
desire by the constituents and by the
elected officials of new hampshire four
years ago to get us over that threshold
and reach net energy metering so that we
could open up the market for
additional
net metering you can sit there
okay
so in addition
net metering is something that the
states around us have been doing
successfully for quite some time we know
that massachusetts has a
4.99999 megawatt limit
maine and vermont have also reached the
same conclusion that it's good for the
market and it's good for creating local
energy
one of the things that we have as a
challenge here in new hampshire is that
aside from nuclear which we are very
good at producing
most of our energy comes from out of
state so we're looking at hydropower
from the north
and
natural gas from pipelines coming from
outside of new hampshire
so increasing the net energy metering
limit would allow us to then open up the
market to increase homegrown energy for
private companies and private businesses
who would like to do larger solar arrays
but right now due to business
constraints are not able to do so
because the numbers just don't make
sense
but in terms of competition and seeing
the other states around us as
competition in the northeast energy
market since we all fall under iso new
england
it makes sense for us to open it up and
increase net energy metering so that we
can be competitive with the states
around us and so that we're not losing
out on these opportunities for solar
developments that are going to other
states because new hampshire is not
considered an opportune state right now
without the increase in net energy
metering
so this the intent of this bill is to
build on the success that we had last
year
which
which if you recall we passed a bill to
allow municipalities to increase their
net energy metering from one to five
megawatts i know that was a huge win for
cities and towns that already had hydro
to go bigger and be able to spin the
meter backwards at a larger scale
and so i'd like to now open it up a
little bit further to private businesses
and large landowners who are looking to
do solar arrays or perhaps large hydro
on a private scale because this would
benefit the private industry as well as
municipalities so with that i'm happy to
take questions
thank you
representative mick williams for that
excellent
introduction of this bill
and
i would now
like to entertain questions from the
committee about this bill
do we have any questions
well i have a question
um i'll go first but then you're next
representative partial
the fiscal note says that the department
of energy indicates that there is the
potential for this for state county and
local governments to see an increase in
expenditures due to the increased cost
of electricity that would result from
passage of this
legislation
do you think that
local
governments would interpret that as the
state downshifting costs onto local
governments
i think it's a little bit more complex
than just saying black and white
increasing net energy metering will
increase the cost of electricity
i think that's a broad statement i think
if we can parse that out a little bit
further
what we're looking at is
individual cost
for a greater good
right so we're talking about increasing
local homegrown energy
individual bills may see a very small
increase in the short term
but in the long term we're talking about
reducing transmission costs because it
is homegrown
so while there may be a little bit of a
curve as we ramp up and increase our
local homegrown solar larger arrays
overall we're going to see a leveling
and possibly reduction in transmission
cost because we are creating our own
energy
so the question about whether
municipalities would see that
uptick in initial cost as a
downshifting i think it really depends
on how you're characterizing it
obviously when the market changes and if
costs change then
there's there's going to be a reaction
from everyone who's involved in the game
but whether we call that a downshift or
just a change because the market has
changed is really a question for how
each municipality interprets the market
and what's happening
i will tell you that as a representative
from concord we have committed to going
to 100 renewable electricity by 2030 as
a city and so we are actively looking at
ways that we can create more
local zero
carbon emissions
electricity right here in concord so for
the city
i don't think they would call that a
downshift i think they would say this is
the cost of doing business because we
have committed to
zero emissions
thank you representative partial was
recognized for a question
thank you chair
thank you for your testimony
representative williams
um can you speak a bit to uh how you
view this is uh would it stabilize our
would it um
would it prove our good stability in new
england or do you think it would be have
any effect at all
well grid stability is a great question
because we've all been following texas
i'm sure um with another deep freeze
happening and folks losing the ability
to control their own heat and
losing power in texas right so grid
stability
comparing new england to texas is a very
different animal
because we are as i mentioned we are all
under the iso new england grid
so the reality is
we have stability in the new england
grid because we have diverse sources of
energy including hydro solar nuclear and
natural gas we're not reliant on just
one type of fuel and we also have
different weather than texas right so we
we make sure that things don't freeze
we've built things to be rated so that
when it gets really cold like it does in
new england and when we have ice storms
we won't lose power unless
obviously a tree falls on transmission
lines that happens and then we have an
immediate response to address that
because that's the market that we're in
so in terms of stability
i would say that adding additional
sources to the mix is always a good
thing
certainly as government officials we are
always looking at the worst case
scenario because we have to worry about
those what-ifs
you know the big fear that there might
be some kind of an attack on our grid
from an outside source is always a real
concern
so as we move forward with the new era
of renewables in new england
talking about things like microgrids
which are self-contained and can
continue producing energy like the um
the durham campus unh durham where
they're looking to do a microgrid that's
self-contained so even if there were an
incident
attack on the grid they would still be
able to contain that specific area with
their own production and still continue
producing it's like its own
generator basically but we're talking
about not a fossil fuel generator but
renewable generation
so big picture using batteries and
renewable technology i think we're
getting closer to diversifying our mix
and therefore concerns about grid
stability are lessened but obviously we
can't say that for the entire state
right we still we heard plenty of
testimony yesterday about how new
hampshire is an interesting state
because we have these dense municipal
areas in the southern portion of the
state and then we are certainly very
rural with vast open tracts of land
north of the notch and so when we talk
about grid stability there still is the
very real concern that not everyone is
stable and depending on weather or
national incidents or local incidents
there's no guarantee or promise so i
would say that adding renewables to the
mix as a general rule is a good thing
it gives us more diversity and with
batteries it gives us more opportunity
to run in a microgrid manner
but this bill isn't really about
microgrids this bill is about enabling
large solar to happen privately
beyond just municipal developments here
in new hampshire so we can keep up with
our neighbors and also so we can have
energy independence and do homegrown
solar
follow-up
no follow-up representative lewicki is
recognized for a question thank you mr
chair and thank you representative i
have two questions um and i don't know
the answers so these are not
by my leading questions one is
and recognizing the synergy between
solar and air conditioning in the summer
that's one piece but what do we get from
solar on a day like this in terms of
percentage of the maximum capacity
sure um this is one of the challenges
with renewables right the sun isn't
always shining
so working with batteries that would be
a time when you'd be drawing from your
solar battery instead of obviously on an
overcast day where it's basically
raining sideways
you're not going to be getting any solar
produced
but the idea here is that we're
diversifying the grids so we've created
something additional to add
and store for those times of peak demand
so it's not just about we have energy
when the sun is shining it is we collect
energy when the sun is shining so that
it can be reintroduced back through
batteries when it is not like today
okay and second question is
are there any major hydro sites that
haven't been exploited i believe that
the amis keg falls is 16 megawatts don't
quote me on that um and are we likely to
find hydro sites that will be in the
megawatts or are those all damned and
already producing power
you're asking about new hydro sites as
opposed to existing i'm not aware of but
that doesn't mean they don't exist i've
certainly heard from hydro producers who
would be interested in being able to
take advantage of this bill who are not
connected with the
municipalities but their existing sites
um so my lack of knowledge doesn't mean
that there isn't one i'm just not aware
of it
thank you further questions
representative pimentel is recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my questions
if someone
if a company wanted to build a 4.99
megawatt array right now
what are their options for selling their
electric their excess electricity
now and how does that compare to
what would happen if your bill was
passed
so right now when you do a development
in new hampshire that's larger than one
megawatt you have to have a dedicated
off taker
so in rare instances where you have a
very large user
it still makes sense to pull the trigger
and do that because you're going to be
producing for yourself or the large user
who's nearby so an example of that would
be a huge manufacturing facility who's
decided that it makes sense to put solar
panels on the roof of their warehouse
because they want to have more than one
megawatt in order to offset their use
it's a business decision
when it comes to utilities as an
off-taker
you could potentially still put in your
4.99 megawatt system and get on the wait
list for the utility to do an analysis
and determine if there's a hookup
potential and what the cost of the
hookup is but you wouldn't be actually
getting the benefit of spinning the
meter backwards beyond the one megawatt
that we currently have so from a
business perspective it doesn't make
sense to look at going back to the
utility you would have to be looking to
go to a private source or i'm sorry a
private off taker
you need a follow-up go ahead
so um
you we would have to
basically sell your
excess electricity
to someone else as opposed to back to
the utility is that what i understand
yes that's correct um and
in in larger scale you know we have
midwestern
renewable sources like wind
that sell their electricity to users in
new england right you can purchase
electricity from an alternative source
beyond just our utilities and so that
kind of a
plan
where you can have a large solar array
or a large wind farm that sells energy
across the nation to consumers who want
to be purchasing renewables that exists
now but i would say that the market in
new hampshire is not really set up for
that because there isn't that additional
benefit of spinning the meter backwards
when it goes into the utility
okay uh representative plett is
recognized for a question thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question you mentioned
that if you go to the utility you may
have to have a distribution analysis
essentially transmission analysis to
make sure it fits and you said that's a
good reason to go to
a business wouldn't that distribution
analysis still have to take place
because there may be a constraint on the
distribution or transmission system
that's a great point representative
plett
whenever you're creating a large amount
of energy you have to make sure that the
off taker is capable of receiving it so
that may include up-sizing the
transmission lines or upgrading the
entire grid between wherever the energy
is being produced and the receiver
so there is a construction cost to
upgrade
regardless of whether it's a private or
a utility off taker
uh representative mcgee is recognized
for a question thank you mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question
so
uh i appreciate you giving the history i
was there for for it but um
i i think my question is around it
appears to me that this bill is designed
to help us
with a transition so that there there's
an economic support for people being
able to invest as they might otherwise
but they wouldn't be getting credit for
the energy they're producing so
um
can you say a little bit about the in
the intent of the bill
in terms of the re the retail energy
market here in new hampshire because i
think we we have a lot of conversations
back and forth about
what we think about that market but when
i look at this bill
i see us struggling to try and put in
something a little more systemic rather
than just scatter shot which is what we
have now in terms of the people who are
willing to invest in new technologies
sure
first i would say that the energy market
in new hampshire wants stability right
we've already seen this at the puc with
our utilities really demanding to have
consistency and stability year over year
with what is it that new hampshire
intends to do for long-term plan
and i think that this bill is part of
that goal to provide consistency and
stability for the energy market as we
ramp up into allowing more than one
megawatt for private projects and i say
allowing because the business
case wouldn't work otherwise
so really
i think the intent here is to ease us
into the next step in our energy
transition to open up to
large-scale renewables and a larger
percentage of our full energy mix in new
hampshire
coming from local sources
and follow up follow up while i have the
mic
um and and so uh
again we also have a conversation
downstream from that is if we implement
this then there will be perhaps costs
somewhere along the chain
and
if you could say something about
whether or not
you think
having this type of competition would
ultimately bring costs down
or how it would bring costs down so that
people could maybe better understand
the intent of that portfolio
diversification sure
so big picture we talked about some
initial startup costs and the
expectation that for municipalities and
for consumers there would be an uptick
in cost in the short term
but over the long term we know that we
would then become more competitive with
our neighboring states now as as we all
know we're all part of the big bathtub
that is iso new england so
every state has their own energy mix and
every state determines uh differently
how that cost is transferred to the
consumer
but big picture the more energy we
produce here in new hampshire the more
local energy with less transmission
distance
the cheaper it's going to be for
everyone who participates every off
taker so unless you are completely off
grid you're going to have an electric
bill and that electric bill is comprised
of the mix of energy that is being sent
to your specific
um let's say it's a residence your
specific home is receiving a mix of
energy and that cost
is sent to you based on as we've talked
about in other hearings the transmission
cost is significant when it's coming
from far away that transmission cost
could be significantly decreased when we
create our own new hampshire solar and
our own new hampshire wind
so this is really intended to move us
forward for the next 10 years and slowly
decrease those transmission costs as
well as the overall cost of energy when
we're seeing huge fluctuations in the
international market for natural gas
and we're all paying the cost for that
this winter even if we're not heating
with electricity we're still seeing our
electric bills go up significantly
because natural gas is a volatile market
so what we're looking to do is introduce
stability with
local solar and wind that is not so
volatile
and based on other factors like wars and
shipping overseas and things like that
representative plett has a question
in the bill
you refer to a default
rate energy rate
that the puc shall apply
i'm looking for the precise words it's
hard to be clerk and uh ask questions at
the same time uh but but uh
isn't that locking the uh
puc into something uh yeah it's a page
three line
18 rather
et cetera and isn't that locking the puc
into something that made the puc and his
judgment may decide is in fact
an unreasonable cost shift
so i'm not going to speak for the puc
um i think that may be a decision for
the puc to make but when we talk default
energy rate that can change that's not
locked in stone so
what it is today is not necessarily what
will be next year on the same day
okay do you need a follow-up
no okay
uh representative thomas is recognized
for a question
thank you miss chair thanks for taking
my question um i'm just curious could
you refer to the page three
line three could you explain to us
exactly
why that paragraph is there and why it's
important or not the version of the bill
i'm looking at doesn't have the line
numbers could you just read the first
test
it's a sub paragraph e
which
paragraph e
i'm sorry paragraph three
roman numeral seven
sub-paragraph e it talks about the um
any provisions of settlement agreements
or orders that have been approved or
issued by the commission
uh blah blah blah uh shall not apply et
cetera et cetera
that paragraph there
could you explain why that's in there
and why is it that's important
i'm going to read it out loud for the
record
any provisions of settlement agreements
or orders that have been approved or
issued by the commission that relate to
a distribution utilities treatment of
the output from qualifying facilities or
independent power producers shall not
apply to the output from an eligible
customer generator participating in net
metering
so we've had some pretty long
discussions about what happens when
somebody installs solar panels on their
house and they decide that they don't
want to take advantage of the wrecks
and wreck sweeping is when those wrecks
go to the utility without any additional
payment to the person who installed the
solar so it's basically a free gift to
the utilities
what i'm seeing here is that somebody
gets the benefit of the net metering as
opposed to the wrecks which go
immediately to the utility so it looks
like
qualifying facilities or independent
producers
will be treated differently than
utilities when it comes to net metering
so perhaps when we're talking about
a utility who is receiving
energy directly from a producer right
someone who's decided to do a 4.99
megawatt
huge solar array
it's going directly to the utility and
so they are net metering because they're
sending it to the utility and there's a
specific rate that the utility will give
them for producing that energy right
especially if it's positive net metering
as opposed to being used for their own
use
but if you're doing an independent power
producer that would be a different rate
altogether because they're using it for
their own use rather than sending it
back to the to the grid for the
utilities use
follow-up
uh thank you um
well you probably explained why
what that paragraph means i'm not
exactly sure i understand
why it needs to be in there but my
follow-up question is
and you mentioned rex uh rex sweeping
would this prevent wreck sweeping
so it doesn't say the word renewable
energy credit
but i
i think that this is something that
could be amended to either make it very
clear that it's intended to be rec
sweeping or not
i think this is more about laying out
the ground rules for how the rate is
applied whether it's used locally or
sent back to the utility but i do think
that looking at rec sweeping as a layer
added to
local solar production is important
we've addressed it with several other
bills we've talked about this year i'm
not sure that that's an animal that i'd
want to add into this bill at this time
but it's something to consider
thank you
okay additional questions i have one
then we'll see if representative
bernardi and callie pitts have questions
my question is
could you describe how this bill differs
from the
three
net metering bills that were vetoed by
the governor since 2019
well
at this point municipal has been
approved by the governor so it doesn't
include municipal it's really just
private um so in that case we've kind of
split the baby right we passed municipal
the governor signed it it's happening
now and municipal's slowly ramping up i
think we'll actually hear from the
department of energy about some
information and data on municipal net
metering as the program continues to
grow
but this bill is really focused on those
who were left behind
so i would say that this is half of a
bill compared to a full bill the last
three times the governor saw it
and so
i guess the ask is
all right we've left these portions of
the industry behind let's allow them to
catch up let's give them the same
benefits that we've given our
municipalities and that's the difference
okay thank you and my follow-up question
would be i have looked at the remote
network service transmission tables for
all the new england states and i don't
see that new hampshire pays any increase
in transmission costs over the other
states why do you think that that
happens
or why do you think that that's true the
statement you made about
new hampshire paying more in
transmission costs
so i would be careful to say that we
don't pay more in transmission costs
than the states around us i would simply
say that because we are receiving um
much of our energy not our nuclear but
much of our other energy from out of
state we are paying those transmission
costs because they're coming to us from
elsewhere so in order to reduce that we
would need to have local sources of
energy to not be paying the transmission
costs so it's not really a
massachusetts maine vermont versus new
hampshire for transmission cost
comparison it is a we all get energy
from other places via natural gas
pipelines etc hydro from canada and so
we're paying those transmission costs
but we can reduce them all of us
individually and specifically for new
hampshire by having local energy that is
not brought from so far away
thank you representative bernardi is
recognized for a question
uh thank you chairman thank you rip uh
williams uh
could you get a little bit closer to you
my question is more more fundamental uh
which is why is this necessary if there
is a desire as you've indicated for
individuals and businesses
to purchase
solar wind hydro power energy now
why why can't they find the users they
need and build their build their uh
three five
four megawatt systems
so that's really a question of the
market we certainly have developers who
would like to do that work in new
hampshire and are choosing to do it in
the surrounding states instead because
there is this additional incentive to do
projects up to 4.99 megawatts in the
states surrounding new hampshire we do
not have those incentives or or the
things that move the market
and so the businesses are choosing not
to put in their own money and take
somewhat of a loss in the short term
because they can make more money where
the low hanging fruit is in the
surrounding states
so unless and until the surrounding
states are completely coated and covered
with every possible site i don't see new
hampshire as being an opportune location
because we don't have the same market
conditions as the states around us but
we can bypassing this bill this creates
that additional incentive to spin the
meter backwards between the one and four
point nine nine megawatt window and so
what we're talking about is a major
market shift we as government actors are
able to change the market by passing
legislation to encourage a direction
that we'd like to see the market to go
and so expecting private actors in a
difficult condition to act that way is
not realistic we know that in capitalism
these contractors are going to select
the lowest hanging fruit which in this
case is generally massachusetts but it
can also be made in vermont it's
certainly not new hampshire for large
solar
follow-up yes
so then you're saying that we we have to
have these incentives or because because
these customers aren't out there they
can't find them
even in massachusetts or vermont or or
maine
so i'm talking about shifting the entire
market right we're we're making a major
change in how we
put energy into the new hampshire
market by incentivizing large solar and
large wind and large hydro
so incentivizing those is a market shift
that shift has already occurred in
massachusetts maine and vermont and so
we're seeing
more and more
medium size to large size arrays pop up
in those locations because the market
has shifted there but not here so we are
in effect being left behind
so it's not so much that there isn't a
need or a desire i will tell you that i
personally purchased my electricity from
100 wind outside of my unitil contract
because i want to do the right thing for
the next generation and for the long
term but i would probably say that
that's not something that most people in
new hampshire even consider they're
really just looking at what is my cost
of electricity and is there any way i
can reduce it right
so when we're talking about making a
market shift
the goal here is let's get more
homegrown electricity let's make it here
in new hampshire let's be proud of
something that we can do and let's
create that market
so it's not that there isn't the desire
it's simply that at such a large scale
you're not going to see independent
actors making much of a difference for a
drop in the bucket
okay thank you representative callie
pitts has a question
oh she pit i'll pass for now okay she
passes all right representative lowkey
has a question
um thank you mr chairman thank you
representative um
it's kind of a parallel question
you've mentioned batteries
and before we can reduce either base
load or transmission then we would need
to have the renewables be able to store
enough energy to ride through whatever
time that might be
because otherwise we're still going to
just revert to base load thank you
um was that a question
i agree
are the batteries how big are the
batteries how long can they last
sure
so there have been some really
interesting pilot studies on large-scale
batteries in massachusetts i believe
this is on the south shore near the cape
so these are like if you look at
an 18-wheeler that has the big old box
on the back of it right that you can
move around
we're talking about that size
full of batteries
that can contain enough to run for two
or three days for you know 10 or 20
houses
so what we're doing is creating a box
with batteries that can run during a
complete electric shutdown for a couple
of days for a neighborhood
and
that's not so far away right now in
terms of technology
and i certainly would like to get some
more information on the unh durham
project because i believe it's a similar
concept of we want to be completely
self-contained and able to run even if
it's a snowstorm for three days the sky
is gray we want to be able to draw from
our backup
okay follow
follow up
thank you
we're talking i'm just kind of trying to
mix take oranges and oranges so if we
have a 5 megawatt
solar facility
how big would the battery have to be to
be able to ride through several days
because that's a whole lot more than 20
houses
sure um i i don't actually play solar
developer on tv
um so there may be some folks in this
room who have a little bit more
information than me on the actual scale
but
it would be
that size of you know a semi-trailer
truck box
times however many are necessary to
provide the planned backup for the scale
of the solar i can't tell you exactly
whether that's a quarter acre or half
acre compared to the full array but
there's some math for the amount of time
and duration that you intend to have a
backup for
and just to spin off that question i
also think that here in new england we
are not doing ourselves any favors
by not doing time of use
costing
because obviously when the solar is
happening in the middle of the day and
we're getting a lot of solar energy into
the grid that could be stored in
batteries that's the cheapest
electricity it's in the evenings when
everyone comes home and they're doing a
load of laundry and the dishes and turn
up the electric heat for those folks who
have it that's the time of use when
there's real demand
let's confine this discussion to the
bill in question thank you
representative mirner is uh recognized
for a question
yes
recently we just
there was a big scale project up in
littleton proposed and it was rejected
by the town because they just didn't
understand it because they were over 30
like what storage
and so representative harrington filed a
bill to make it a separate class so that
the set evaluation committee can
actually sit in you know be part of the
process for them to get this to get it
through um so i mean it's being looked
at and that was the first big skill when
i know in the state of new hampshire
that was filed so um
so it we have they are looking at it
because that will take that what you're
talking about the instability out
thank you i'm going to suggest at this
point that we move on we have three more
people signed up to testify on this bill
we're down to our last 22 minutes or so
representative mick williams has done an
outstanding job of explaining what the
bill does how it manipulates the market
etc so let's move on and i'd like to uh
thank you representative mick williams
i'd like to
i'd like to call on
mark brown of the consumer energy
alliance
good morning mr brown it's all yours
good morning
good good to be back before the
committee in person
um
chairman vo's members of the committee
uh for the record my name is mark brown
i am the executive director of new
england for consumer energy alliance
cea is a nationwide association made up
of both energy producers and consumers
working to advance in all the above
energy and environmental policies that
will lower energy costs for everyone
cea supports actions that thoughtfully
advance our nation toward a cleaner more
environmentally responsible energy
future
while also considering the needs of
consumers
so on behalf of cea i want to thank for
the opportunity to testify here today
cea supports new hampshire families
municipalities businesses making
investments in generation that will
allow them to produce their own power
and sell that power back to the grid
there is no legislative or regulatory
hurdle prohibiting this from happening
now
um as is always the case with these
bills the issue is at what
compensation you know for systems one to
five megawatts
purple requires utilities to purchase
their power at avoided cost so there you
know there is a market there for that
now
um so i just want to just touch on that
um
the other thing i want to talk about is
you often hear about um and i think
representative williams brought it up is
about this transmission cost savings
um i passed around
a sheet there and it's not it shouldn't
be seen as anything that's you know
totally conclusive um
because there's a lot that goes into
transmission costs
but if you look at the it's a 12 month
rolling average of you know regional
load okay and this goes month to month
and it's from december of 2014 through
december 2021.
um you can't see it on the on the on the
graph that i sent out but if you look at
let's start at the top with
massachusetts you know you go all the
way to the left in december 14
their allocation was 46.2 percent of the
you know of regional transmission
by december 21 you know it's 45.7 so
keep in mind the transmission market is
about two it's about a two billion
dollar market
so
each tenth of a percentage point
represents two million dollars okay so
in theory massachusetts would be saving
uh 10 million dollars in annual
transmission costs right if you look at
it that way
connecticut starts out at 25.3 and goes
down to 24.4
new hampshire 9.4 and goes up to 9.7
now again this isn't meant to be you
know definitive or absolute or anything
like that but it's pretty clear that
you know massachusetts has spent
literally in that time frame tens of
billions of dollars on behind the meter
and energy efficiency and things to you
know reduce load
um and they haven't really substantially
reduced their transmission costs
um during that time frame so i think
that's you know i think this somewhat
illustrative of what might happen
um or what is happening
probably
um
you know i'm not i've sat before this
committee before and i've talked about
studies and i'm happy to provide the
committee with any studies that i
reference today and but there's there's
plenty of studies out there that show
that net metering policies are socially
regressive
that non-adopters pay for more of the
you know the distribution system
than solar doctors do
solar doctors tend to be more wealthy
than non-solar adopters you know 2021
lawrence berkeley lab study
i think the average median income for a
typical solar owner was
113 thousand dollars where i think the
u.s averages around
000 so that's pretty substantial
difference that has come down i think in
2010 the average solar owner had an
income of about 140 median income about
140 000
um so we know we know it's it's pretty
socially regressive
you know massachusetts has
puts into its tariffs you know
low-income adders
to offset the costs in massachusetts of
the behind the meter
systems
i think it's probably exceeding over 100
million dollars now
um
so i want to talk about a few things
about market so this would this would
create a you know this would compensate
systems at one to five megawatts at the
default service rate which we know is
well above market rates even with
um
you know the price of natural gas on the
rise right now
we've passed legislation
for community you know for community
power community choice aggregation
however you want to look at it that
should create a market for larger
systems you know more towns adopting
you know increasing you know green
programs
more net zero more 100 percent renewable
that should develop the market for these
size for these size systems
um
as far as you know
again kind of flipping back to
transmission costs you know new
hampshire we are
we are part of a regional grid as
representative williams stated
but if you look at it strictly from you
know energy produced and energy consumed
electricity produced in energy consumed
as far as in terms of megawatt hours
well the new hampshire would be
considered actually an exporter of
energy
so you know between the the nuclear
plants between granite ridge and
londonderry
between you know the hydros and the and
the wind and then and the solar
we produce more electricity in the state
than we actually consume
than just wanted to touch on that um
so you know i think
i think with that i guess i'll just
conclude my testimony i'll be happy to
take any questions
um
and again if anybody wants to i'll be
happy to afford any studies
um they're you know mit stanford cal
berkeley um pretty conclusive studies
that show that
expanding that metering is
socially regressive so
thank you mr brown representative plett
has a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question mr brown you say
we're a net exporter of energy
would installing more
net metering local facilities increase
that net export and therefore increase
the need for transmission
i mean that that's depending on what
other states do and you i mean
it's it's complicated right it's not
it's not that simple um it depends on
what happens in the market you know
i guess what i would say is
the more
we
incentivize you know through state
policies
other resources
it's going to
creates price suppression on existing
resources
like nuclear plants that rely heavily on
energy market revenue not capacity
market revenue
and you know it would potentially put
those plants at risk i know you know
when vermont when vermont yankee retired
in i think it was 2014 2015 there are a
host of reasons why it retired but one
of the reasons they gave was they were
concerned about what was going to happen
with energy markets down the road and
potential price suppression effects and
thus their revenue
from state policies
you know
immediately after that emissions rose i
think it was seven percent in the next
year after they retired so
i think there's a kind of a bigger
picture here and i know i didn't fully
answer your question but i think it's
more complicated than just saying if we
if we install a bunch of five megawatt
systems in new hampshire well then we're
going to create you know transmission
problems it could
you know it could especially if let's
say seabrook were to retire
well now you're really moving power
you know from other areas you know into
new hampshire we already know there's
congestion constraints on the mass
excuse me on the main new hampshire
border so even if you bring hydro in
from canada through maine
there's got to be infrastructure
built to carry that power into new
hampshire so it's more complicated than
just a i think a yes or no follow-up
follow-up yes um there's been testimony
about desirability of
local generation
um
i gave testimony the other day about a
situation in my town
uh trash to energy people hated the idea
but it was okay in maine so we shipped
our trash to maine
is it is it uh
is so is it the eye of the beholder
whether local generation is desirable or
not yeah and i think that applies to any
any resource it doesn't matter you know
you're seeing
solar projects rejected in towns like
northampton massachusetts they don't
want to see any you know large-scale
solar projects so you're seeing it in
maine um i think level main is the town
um you know we've seen it with wind
we've seen it with transmission lines
you know
um so
there you call it nimbyism call it
whatever you want but yeah there's gonna
there's probably gonna be opposition to
you know to anything
uh representative knotter is recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question mr brown good to see
you again good to see you um i keep
hearing the word incentivize but what do
you mean exactly by that does it mean
redistribution of wealth
well i think i do believe you know that
net metering is regressive so yes it is
i do believe it generally favors the the
more wealthy at the expense of those
less fortunate um and i think that the
evidence shows that
um
and as far as incentives go you know
this bill
would incentivize it would make payments
to systems from one up to you know 4.999
megawatts to avoid further jurisdiction
um
above market rates
so that's you know
and above the the
prescribed avoid cost rate which in new
hampshire is pretty much the lmp so
representative mcgee is recognized for a
question
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
brown for taking my question
um it's an interesting conversation
we're having and it always comes down to
you know which points we're being
asked to look at
in your graph here it's a rolling
average of regional load and i guess my
initial question i have to
would be
is regional load
based on uh
populations and industry that the state
serves based on peak it's based on
monthly peaks those are monthly peaks
and those peaks are not related to
the population use no it's transmission
peaks just transmission yeah okay
all right and then the second thing is
the point on socially uh regressive i
think you know
i think that the bill in looking at
diversity is saying we don't have a plan
here in new hampshire right we don't
have an understanding of where we're
going in terms of
seabrook and you know so all of this is
speculation in terms of what is the mix
going to be in 10 years we don't have a
plan that tells us where we're going
and
i think on the question of socially
regressive that you were trying to make
um
my understanding is that it it's not
socially regressive if you are trying to
take into account
the climate effects that
disproportionately affect the poor
so i think
it is looking at what is socially
regressive in terms of our energy
decisions to try and
put policies in place that help prevent
those in the lower income rungs from
being affected by the decisions we're
making today on our energy
okay well those are you know probably
difficult to quantify
um i would say you know from an
emissions perspective especially with
co2
one new hampshire has the lowest
emissions per megawatt hour produced in
the region largely due to seabrook yep
you know
but
it's a fact nonetheless
the u.s itself has reduced emissions by
about 17 percent between 2005 and 2019
so we're kind of leading the world in
that area
um
we're exporting emissions to some extent
to other countries that are less
environmentally responsible than we are
so i would say you know there's
trade-offs to any policy
um
when i talk about socially regressive
you know you look at a lot of the
studies have been done in states that
have far more advanced you know
renewable energy policies in new
hampshire massachusetts
california obviously a lot of studies
have been done there
illinois
but it does show significant cost shifts
from
generally solar adopters to non-solar
adopters and we've seen you know as as
in the case with california they're
importing a lot of power from arizona
which is heavily dependent on coal
they're building new gas plants to you
know the la county is building a new gas
plant to support its municipal system
because
they need
the reliability there so there's a lot
of trade-offs so i would just say that
uh
you know
yeah there may be benefits on this end
and there's definitely benefits to the
recipient of the net metering program
but there's a lot of other factors that
you need to look at as well
so and there's some evidence to show
that it's it's not good for everybody
thank you representative samsich is
recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony mr brown
um
i'm kind of surprised by some of your
your comments uh because we have had
numerous testimony and
documents provided to us by des
here at this committee over the past two
or three years
who have consistently said
that transmission costs are rising
compared to the other neighboring states
they've said this over and over again
they've documented it it's in our
four-year energy strategy plan are you
saying that they're wrong
i'm saying that if you pick an arbitrary
beginning point then you can come up
with any you know you can kind of show
anything you want to show and what i
would say is
you know
it's not just about the it shouldn't be
looked at as just the transmission cost
what did it cost to reduce those
those transmission numbers
you know again massachusetts to spend
tens of billions of dollars
tens of billions of dollars on
distributed generation energy efficiency
to move the needle slightly
so you know just saying that oh well you
know
our car our our share of the regional
network load is up a little bit or even
if it's up a full point
okay well if massachusetts is
spending more money than it is saving
then it doesn't make a lot of sense to
do it
follow up follow up
uh and um you know we're talking about
the
future perspective of energy supply in
new hampshire
how do you see the impact of the
offshore wind industry which probably
will be impacting us within the next 10
years on the energy prices that people
that new hampshire will be paying or new
england for that matter
i think that
offshore wind is promising but you know
it needs to provide benefits to the
consumer as well and if those contracts
are for you know firm power at
reasonable rates great
you know but if you know if it's going
to be for intermittent power where
you're managing risk and and all that
sort of thing and it increased costs on
the other side
you know
i think it the the proof is in the
pudding is there is there potential an
offshore win absolutely i'm not going to
argue that with you at all
but i do think it a lot depends on how
the contracts are structured
and
you know obviously how the projects are
developed
and what capacity factors those
projects are going to have
that's all things that are going to
matter but i'm i'm not going to argue
that the potential benefits of offshore
wind with you here
thank you okay thank you representative
bernardi is recognized for a question
thank you chairman thank you uh mr brown
uh as you've noted uh
net metering incentives means increased
cost to the consumers
uh do you have an estimate
uh
for this bill what where what what kind
of increased costs we'd be looking at i
i mean i could
sit down and do some back of the
envelope math but no and i think this
actually you bring up a good point
because
the the
doe i guess now is you know
we're waiting for a study
to be completed that has been part of an
ongoing docket at the puc you know
the net metering tariff talk at the
16-576
and there's a study that's going to be
coming out of that i think it's supposed
to be late spring
and i think it would do do us all good
to put pause on some of these net
metering bills to wait to see
what that study shows it may not again
it's not probably going to be conclusive
it's not going to be you know probably
oh yeah you have to do this or or
whatever
but it should provide us with more
information as to what the impact of net
metering is on new hampshire right now
and will better inform us down the road
on policies again
some of us may agree or disagree with
whatever the study shows but at least
we'll have more information to go by
okay thank you with that i'm going to
call on the
i'm going to thank mr brown for his very
informative testimony and call on the
next
uh presenter who will be
our good friend griffin roberge from the
department of energy
by the way
uh
we're running out of time
that was allocated for this public
hearing
so i will be
starting the next public hearing
properly at ten o'clock and then
recessing it
until we finish this public hearing
so mr robarge
it's all yours thank you chairman votes
members of the committee uh for the
record griffin roberge from the
department new hampshire department of
energy
here to respectfully oppose house bill
it's largely for
two reasons that have been discussed
as noted in the fiscal note and as mr
brown
just said moments ago
the department is currently working on
it with a consultant to study issues
related to the value of distributed
energy resources
in the state
that study is
meant to provide policy makers state
agencies as well as other stakeholders
some type of guidance as to the value of
these resources there that is new
hampshire centric and using new
hampshire-centric data
it is part of an ongoing puc docket and
again for reference it's de
16-576
and it is expected that that study will
be completed in late spring of this year
the department just thinks that this
bill is premature at this time pending
the outcome of that study
while um
this bill would largely expand net
metering
you know to the extent that there may or
may not be cost shifting this bill would
likely
exaggerate that i think the department
would like to see what the study has to
ultimately finds
in that direction
as i know the committee is certainly
well aware
house bill
315 was signed into law last year
along with
other language in senate bill 91
that had a very targeted and modest
increase beyond the one megawatt net
metering cap for municipal hosts it
allows
public private entities to net meter for
the benefit of political subdivision or
i should say group net meter for the
benefit of political subdivisions
to date there are currently four
municipal hosts in the state registered
there's one in their all all four
hydroelectric facilities but they're
located in milton
berlin gorham and hillsborough i
couldn't give any ideas to what type of
applications might come in the future
but that's currently uh what is in
operation for municipal hosts in the
state uh certainly we'll only answer any
questions that the committee might have
um
that concludes my testimony
thank you for
uh excellent testimony on this bill
questions for mr roberge representative
samsich
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
roberts for coming um
my understanding is that we've had
several documents and testimonies from
puc as well as from other agencies who
said that in light of our very low
penetration of renewable energy in this
state
there is no observable cost shifting
that we could see up to this point
would you agree with that i believe that
there was and it
put me on the spot i can't remember the
docket number or the the document or
anything like that right now but i think
there was some years ago there was a
conclusion that there wasn't any
noticeable effect of cost shifting based
on the data at that time and i believe
that was
three four years ago or something like
that again doing this all from memory
and i'll certainly follow it by email
but again
factors certainly change over time
that's for certain um and so that's why
uh the department would respectfully
like to request
further study on this issue with
this study that's expected out in late
spring to get further information as to
the true value of these distributed
energy resources and its impact on the
state
follow-up
yes
could you do you have any ideas i i
agree with you i think it was three or
four years ago that we heard this
something like that
well how much
what what kind of increase have we seen
in renewable energy since that three
four years since then sure so that would
make a difference perhaps obviously
there is the renewable portfolio
standard that's the state's renewable
energy
policy tool that encourages the
or i should say incentivizes and
encourages the development of renewable
energies in the state every year that
goes by
various class obligations increase over
time so off the top of my head that's
certainly one that encourages the
further development of renewable energy
resources in the state
obviously there was the passage of the
municipal host bill last year that's
obviously encouraged at least four
projects to come online and group net
meter for the benefit of municipalities
and their local property taxpayers um i
couldn't offer anything substantial but
you know in terms of renewable energy
and maybe it's expansion i'm sure it
will likely be discussed in the study
that comes out later this year excuse me
that was not my question i asked you
whether or not
how much has changed in the last three
or four years you were saying there are
all these incentives in place to do
things but i wanted to know how much has
changed since then to change the opinion
maybe of what we heard three years ago
oh of the study um you know obviously
there's been a targeted increase with
municipal hosts again as i said
certainly market factors are also a
thing to take into consideration i
couldn't comment substantially you know
i'm not involved uh intricately in the
study and what it's currently looking at
but um
i can certainly you know try to get you
a more concrete answer and follow up
with you
thank you very much
we do know that install solar has
doubled in that time period
i'm going to take a quick pause here and
i'm going to open the public hearing on
house bill 1599-fn
and then i'm going to recess that public
hearing until we complete this public
hearing which hopefully won't take too
much longer
more questions for mr roberge
representative callie pitts
all right cam rich mr uh robert if i as
a private citizen
wanted to put up
a 4.99 megawatt solar array
and had to connect that array
to the grid the transmission grid
who would pick up
the cost for that would it be me
or would it be the company
or would it be split
how would that be funded
if private entity were to construct a
system in excess of one megawatt um
you know i i mean obviously the cost
will be borne by that private entity
obviously installing the system and all
of its relevant aspects in terms of
upgrading you know a distribution system
or transmission system
i'd have to do a deeper dive but i
anticipate that those costs would
likely be
imposed upon
the utility which would then be shared
amongst its ratepayers for probably cost
recovery but again like to do a deeper
dive and not lead you astray with an
incorrect answer
follow up
i i'm having a hard time hearing you so
that's
um
one of my concerns and i don't know if
the department of energy would look into
this or if departments cross
cross
areas
but is that if
most of the cost is borne by
ratepayers
perhaps
more people
would be more interested in selling
electricity than tomatoes
is that
a valid concern
i'm not
sure i understand you're i i guess
you're saying
people would be further incentivized to
sell electricity rather than sell
tomatoes using your analogy
your or your references yes and that
electricity if it goes out onto the grid
can go anywhere it doesn't have to stay
in my mind
what i understand in new hampshire no
and and that's true but obviously if
people
net meter it tends to be
for the benefit of those largely in the
surrounding area as i think you're well
aware you know the longer
the longer
in distance electricity needs to travel
you know
the more expensive yes correct
okay thank you any further questions
representative mcgee is recognized yes
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
robash for taking my question
um i i'm
going to refer back to what you said in
your opening you talked about the fact
that the doe is opposed to the bill
specifically because there's a pending
value of der study going on at the
relatively newly formed doe and then you
mentioned that there was also a dock
that opened at the puc
that starts with de16 can you explain to
people what that 16 stands for i'm sorry
16 references um the year that the
docket was created and so so it's it's
six years that we've been waiting for
that that would work yes thank you for
the clarification yeah so i just wanted
to say that for some of us that have
been you know working in this field for
a while while we're asking questions
right right well while you're saying
that it's premature i guess i would
i would suggest to you that we've been
waiting a really long time for someone
to give us a definitive answer
and so
um
when you talk about the
pending study of the value of der that's
going on at doe could you give us an
anticipated time frame for when we might
be seeing those results yeah late spring
of this year um
yeah that's it that's at least outlined
in the fiscal note that's the
anticipated um
anticipated conclusion of the study
thank you
okay thank you mr robarge for your
testimony and
we'd like to move on now to our final
speaker
on this
bill and that is sam evans brown
representing clean energy new hampshire
or did you submit this pink card for the
next bill uh that's correct i was not
planning on testifying on this bill
okay
we'll be calling on you shortly then
all right so that exhausts our pink
cards for this bill and
concludes basically our discussion or
our public hearing on this bill so
i will now close the public hearing on
house bill
1506 uh
and quickly
require or ask representative pimentel
to give us blue sheet information about
this bill
while he's fetching that information
what we will do
is we will take a five minute
bio break
and we will return to this room at no
later than 10 15
to
resume the public hearing on house bill
1599.
so representative pimentel what'd you
find uh three
names or on the blue sheet
all are
in favor of the bill
and then on the online version
there were 95 in support three opposed
and one neutral
okay thank you we are in uh recess until
10 15.
thank you
i don't think
yes
oh yeah for sure
um
the idea
i don't think
it will be
oh yeah yeah
um
okay
[Music]
he's very strong
foreign
i'd like to call
like to call the order please
hp's 1599
and
before we start i would like to comment
that in the interest of time please
limit our
speakers to about five minutes and i
will be very strict on clarification
questions any statements made for
clarification
will be okay but will be suspended if
they become just statements
so
please respect that and i'd like to
introduce and welcome representative
vose to introduce 15.99
you mr vice chairman
and good
uh morning actor i guess it is good
morning to all my uh colleagues on the
committee
for the record i'm representative
michael boze i represent rockingham
district nine the town of epping and i'm
here to introduce house bill 1599-fn
to the committee so this bill is a
relatively simple bill
it
uses language that was actually proposed
in a committee of conference last year
when we were having deliberations on
house bill 15 and senate bill 91
and this language essentially says
that if you are a customer generator
of renewable energy
that engages in net energy media
metering
you cannot be
paid for renewable portfolio standard
charges
you cannot be credited rather for
renewable portfolio
standard charges
when you are credited for your net
metering supply to the grid
it's a fairly simple change and
the language may be
puc speak
as they call it
but it uh does one simple thing and it
just says that
if you are a net energy meter
you need to pay
your poor your fair share of rps charges
and can't receive credits for those
charges
it's no more complicated than that
and
doesn't require a lot of explanation
so with that
i'll open the floor to questions and
we'll go on from there
uh representative um mcgee you're uh
recognized for a question thank you mr
acting chairman uh and thank you
chairman bose for taking my question
um i guess my question would be how
would this affect the existing
uh participants in the market
it would lower the credit that any net
metering customer currently gets they
currently get the default service rate
it would essentially subtract from that
credit default service credit the cost
of compliance with the rps okay and may
follow up follow up and to what end
though what is the hope of the bill
the purpose of the bill is to
require that net metering customers pay
their fair share of the renewable
portfolio standard
if they're given a credit
when they
for their rps portion
then they are essentially not paying
for their portion of the rps
that would shift costs onto the rest of
us
i only get two questions right
so far
representative sausage you're recognized
for a question with a queue
yes thank you mr chairman uh thank you
uh representatives um can you clarify
for me again
is currently what what is the current
practice if if you are a customer
generator
and net metering so you get credit
for your the energy you put into the
grid
and you're saying that that portion on
your electric bill
that is assigned to the rps
you don't pay that is that the current
practice that we were saying
no i s what i said was that if this bill
passed
the practice would change
current practice is yes
that's what i'm asking what is the
current practice yes
if you generate
more than 100 kilowatts of electricity
and you net meter
you get default service credits
for the
energy that you put onto the grid the
default service credit includes the cost
of the rps that the utility
i see that's included in the defaults
yes okay thank you
seeing no other questions i thank
representative votes for your very
informative testimony
and i will call on
i'd like to call on a
public speaker mr
kwasner kwasnik
please come up
can you turn your mic on please
and get a little bit closer is it on
okay okay thank you sorry
again thank you mr chairman and uh the
committee for the opportunity to testify
on this bill my name is joe kwoznick and
i'm a citizen of concord and i'm a
founding member of the new hampshire
network for environment energy and
climate which is about a year old and
we're working as a coordinating and
communicating function among like groups
within new hampshire i'm also a former
chairman of the new hampshire electric
cooperative
and retired environmental executive for
national grid
i am today submitting a written
testimony which i submitted
electronically this morning in
opposition to host bill 1599 my reasons
for opposing the bill are as follows and
these reasons are what you've heard on
the previous bill today
one is that the bill changes the basis
for compensation for new customer
generators within a total peak
generating capacity of greater than one
megawatt
the bill states the commission order uh
26029 from june 23
shall be applicable except for the cost
of compliance with the electrical
renewable portfolio standard and a few
words after that uh just a little bit of
history in june of 2017 the puc
established the current net metering
tariffs
in those tariffs the puc established its
view that the new tariffs avoided any
significant cost shifting among in
between customer rate classes
rate classes
currently the puc is studying the value
of distributed energy resources a
program called referred to as a vder
and would be expected to make any
adjustments to the net metering credit
tariffs if necessary to avoid cost
shifting between customer classes
given the current schedule for issuing
his report on vder now scheduled for the
spring of this year
the legislation should wait this
legislation should wait for the puc to
issue its report and recommendations
before developing any new legislation in
this area
unilaterally adjusting
the various components of credits or
debits for nate metering net metering
customer generators without the benefit
of the com upcoming vdr study
it's inappropriate and cannot properly
evaluate the benefits and costs of net
metering
let the puc proceed on developing the
vder study and then act on the
conclusions of the study as necessary
this building this bill
is unnecessary and premature it should
be determined to be an expedient to
legislate
you know prepare to take questions
uh thank you mr kwoznick uh
representative plet's recognized for a
question thank you i'm asking this
question is clerk would you please spell
out pter
um
vder is called the value
of distributed energy resources in my
apologies
and i don't
i don't envy your position at all
[Laughter]
okay uh seeing no questions uh thank you
mr kwasnik for your testimony appreciate
it and you said that the written
testimony was it was emailed to us it
was easy okay very good thank you so
much thank you appreciate it very much
next i'd like to call up
for real this time
sam evans brown
from clean energy new hampshire
mr sam evans welcome thank you so much
thank you mr chair
um i'll try to be brief i i think
clean energy new hampshire has been
engaged in
the the various proceedings at the
public utilities commission that set the
net metering rates
for
for years now
and
i would say that
generally speaking
we recognize the principle that this
bill is based on um and it's it's sound
in principle
but the issue is that it's looking
simply at one side of the ledger right
so so net metering um
i think even its most
resolute proponents
would recognize that net metering is is
a is a policy that gives rough justice
to
distributed energy resources it was not
a policy that was designed
terribly
conscientiously or thinking about uh the
markets the market structures that it
was playing into it was simply the
easiest way to roll out distributed
energy at a time decades ago in which we
did not have a terribly uh
great number of options technologically
speaking to integrate those resources
into the grid but also it was
recognizing that these technologies were
in were sort of an
infant stage and we didn't necessarily
need a terribly
uh well-developed policy at that time we
just we just needed to try some things
and as that policy has developed and
changed over the course of years
we have we have recognized that we
should be developing market structures
that are more reflective of the cost and
benefits
of these types of technologies that are
that are deployed at the edge of the
grid on the distribution grid which is
in the way that the grid is designed
today is is not typically where
generation resources have been deployed
traditionally
that said
the the problem with this bill and the
reason why clean energy new hampshire
opposes it is that it's is looking at
just one
aspect of this really complicated
question of what are the costs and
benefits of deploying generation
resources
in a system that wasn't necessarily
designed for them to be deployed in
those places and there are benefits uh
there's they're numerous we could look
at the reduction in the the amount that
our our distribution utilities have to
pay into the regional capacity markets
we've talked already this morning about
the amounts that the utilities pay for
their demand their their transmission
charges um and there are more and if you
were if any of the representatives here
were interested we could walk through
the value of distributed energy
resources study that's underway which is
very comprehensive and is in fact
looking at all of these questions um and
so so i would say simply that uh there
is a process underway that is that is
looking at these questions in a really
fulsome manner and there's no need for
the legislature to weigh in at this time
because that process is playing out at
the public utilities commission and it
will look at questions like the one that
this bill addresses so with that i'll
take any questions
yes representative kelly pitts
recognized for a question
do you believe that when the
study is released
the public utilities commission will
take efforts to change the formula it is
my understanding that that is that that
is how how things will go and then it
will likely happen through a
an officially adjudicated docket that
goes through the entire formal puc
process um and all the parties will be
allowed to weigh in on the evidence
that's presented
oh
will that be
i know you can't speak for the puc but
will that daca take
as long as what
this first study is taking
uh
you know predicting what happens at the
poc i think is a bit like predicting
what will happen at the u.s supreme
court uh and so i will decline to make a
prediction in that regard i would say
that it was my personal hope uh that it
would it would be more expeditious than
than what has you know
to to to just take one step back the the
net metering docket is uh one of the
most complex and longest running dockets
at the new hampshire public utilities
commission most dockets do not take that
long so i would hope that it would be
faster
well although it i
someone who who is more in the pvc
process than me could answer this it may
actually take place as part of that
docket in fact i actually believe that
but i'm i'm speaking out of turn i'm not
actually 100 certain about that thank
you
represent cali pitch question
i'm sorry representative mcgee excuse me
thank you
thank you mr chairman
um so
it sounds to me like
i will paraphrase what i think you're
saying which is that the solution that's
being proposed by this bill
is
um
is making assumptions that we don't yet
have the answers to because there's
pending work being done on some very
complex calculations that would give us
a better understanding of whether we
should do it or not
um
i i would i would nuance the my answers
slightly and say i think that the the
cost of renewable portfolio compliance
is is actually a fairly
well established and and understandable
number that that one could one could
proceed with um with this bill what i
would say though is that it's it's only
one small part of what goes into the net
metering tariff and considering it in
isolation increasing it or reducing it
um
is is really i think to not doing
justice to to the complex task that is
rate making and that we should let the
puc do what it does which is m make
rates
thank you
yes representative platt
yes given the answer you just gave
could this bill go ahead
be implemented and then the puc adjusts
what it otherwise might have done as a
result of the study that's going to be
concluded in the spring
i i believe
that
that certainly it's up to the discretion
of this chamber as to what it's going to
do uh i i'm not suggesting that it is uh
not within the authority of the house of
representatives to to weigh in on this
question i'm simply suggesting that
it doesn't strike me as a terribly sound
way to make public policy to be to be uh
picking and choosing the types of ways
that the general court intervenes in
utility rate making and uh and that
there is a process ongoing and so it
strikes me that this bill is unnecessary
at this time
seeing no other questions thank you for
your testimony thank you
the chair will call up um
heidi cole and madeline minnow from
granite state hydrogen association
thank you for coming this morning good
to see you back here again
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record my name is
heidi kroll i work at gallagher callahan
and gartrell and i represent
granite state hydropower association
with me here today is madeline minnow
now working with essex hydro which is a
member of granite state hydropower
association so
she and i are here to answer questions
so we appreciate your time this morning
i think our testimony is probably going
to sound similar to the testimony you've
just heard from
clean energy new hampshire we are
urging or requesting that this committee
find this bill in expedient to legislate
and
again recognizing the principle that's
being discussed here um but asking that
you please kind of pause and look at the
context that we currently find ourselves
in so first as you've heard
the puc is nearing the end of a lengthy
and in-depth process to study the value
of distributed energy resources and it
began in the summer of i believe it was
following a docket
an order in a docket de16576
and that docket actually was open
pursuant to passage of a bill in 2016
which was house bill 1116
relative to net metering and so all the
parties in that docket including the
utilities the consumer advocates
renewable advocates the office of energy
and planning at the time all agreed to
the adoption of alternative net metering
tariffs
to be in effect during the period of
time during which data would be
collected
pilot programs would be implemented
studies would be conducted and so there
was consensus around that
and obviously for the past five or so
years the
puc and now the department of energy
staff and a diverse group of
stakeholders have really invested a
significant amount of time and effort
and money
consultants have been hired to undertake
the research and the analysis
needed to better understand the value of
distributed energy resources and so as
you've heard that study will expect
expected to be completed in late spring
um and so we would simply ask you not to
kind of do an end run around the study
process which was carefully designed and
agreed to
by a broad group of stakeholders
the second piece of that was that
as part of that
the
parties all agreed that at a minimum
the default service rate should be
the um
the credit for net metering until the
study was completed um and so again we'd
ask that you just honor that agreement
that was reached among the parties um
across the board in that docket
um and the final point that we would
like to make and i think you've heard
this this morning is simply
recognizing that there is a lot of value
we believe
around distributed energy resources and
the
excess energy that's put onto the grid
in terms of avoided transmission cost
avoided capacity costs obviously
environmental benefits and so
again we're just concerned about looking
at one side of the ledger and making a
reduction without looking at
all of the um pluses and minuses that
would that should be under consideration
um
so you know we're looking and i think
everybody is looking for to make sure
that compensation is fair um and
obviously minimizing cost shifting as
well but i think we really want to make
sure that we're looking at this kind of
fair and balanced way so um with that
we'd be happy to answer any questions
and again we're respectfully requesting
that you vote no at this time on this
bill spill
i'll just add
one thing is that several of our members
as you heard from the department of
energy our small hydros are the early
adopters of the municipal host provision
that was passed just last year and we
have additional members that are
currently negotiating member agreements
for group net metering with
municipalities and counties and schools
based on law that was just passed last
year which has a certain level of net
metering credit in it and so
we would ask for consistency and not
changing
the laws or the rules or the credit
value every year so that we may
in good faith negotiate with members
and that if the credit value
diminishes that will diminish the value
that is then given to those members
and the municipal host provision was
passed with the intention of having a
limited focused net metering expansion
that was going to directly benefit
municipalities counties and schools
and so
i would ask that we sort of stay the
course and as has been mentioned let the
value of dr study continue
to answer a question that was asked
previously
if this law passes
the puc could not then
reinstate the credit because the pc
can't override laws and so if the
legislature passes laws
unless you explicitly give the puc the
authority to change it or override it
they would not be able to do that and so
i think that we should let that study
see its course and the docket process
follow as it should
thank you mr noah riverstein kelly
you have a question
yes
i
i understand that about the laws that
that the puc can't
but the
legislature
can always override the puc with the law
is that correct yes that's correct
follow-up
in my world which has
kind of gone topsy-turvy because i'm not
quite sure of who does what where and
when
is this still an adjudicative decision
and with the force
with the ability to force rulemaking
with the puc or is it a combined
decision
between the department of energy and the
puc
um i can explain to you my understanding
is that the department of energy took
over
managing the consultants that are doing
the study and so they are
seeing that process through the study
will be what it is the results will be
presented publicly the public utilities
commission which is the adjudicative
body would then
decide if it should open a new docket
based on the evidence from the study
to then
develop the third generation what would
be the third generation of net metering
tariffs in new hampshire that would go
through an adjudicative docket process
the department of energy
repre is a party to those dockets now
and would represent the state's interest
and so
they could um
be a party to the docket
hire expert witnesses or have their own
staff be expert witnesses and present
evidence
to support
or if they don't like the results of the
study in opposite of the studies to say
why they don't think it was accurate or
to support it if that's the position of
the state just like all the other
parties will be
presenting evidence having witnesses and
being part of the docket
thank
you representative pimentel
thank you mr chairman
um
this
legislation
well the docket that we're talking about
from what i understand you your all
parties are going to be involved and
they are going to look at a fair
market value for
um how to
um
to charge
generators customer generators
this particular bill we're looking at
is
only applying to
new customer generators
first of all
and i'm curious of your opinion of how
that will affect
the um
the increase or or how that will affect
new generators as far as
how how will it uh prevent them
um
would
be a damper on new power generation
um first i would say that uh in our view
the way that new is used in in this
legislation is a bit ambiguous it's
unclear to us if it's um new to
registering as a customer generator or
new to existing
for example a lot of the hydros have
existed
for quite a while have been in service
and generating since the 1980s
however they are newly uh eligible as
customer generators and so
to us it's a little bit ambiguous what
new in this context means but certainly
if the value of that metering credit is
lowered by any amount in this case by
the compliance of the rps cost
the the payback to make investments in
developing new distributed energy
resources will be extended
uh and the value given back to members
that participate in group net metering
will be lowered so
it will certainly not encourage the
development of more new distributed
energy resources
okay see no other further questions
thank you for your time nice testimony
and the chair at this time would like to
call up our last speaker the
our distinguished orator the honorable
clifton balo
i i don't i don't know about that
[Laughter]
some people call me wordy
good good morning um mr chairman and
members of the committee i'm assistant
mayor clifton bilo of the city of
lebanon here to testify on behalf of the
city in support of this legislation
um we are a member of clean energy new
hampshire but we on this bill part ways
with on this
and it might seem uh that
you know it's against our own
self-interest and that of other
municipalities in general and renewable
energy advocates and developers
because it would reduce the default
service energy
default energy service credit that large
group net meter generation projects
receive for their experts exports to the
grid by the amount of the rps compliance
costs that are embedded in those rates
uh the city supports this change in the
compensation rate because it's the right
thing to do
and to eliminate one of the substantial
and problematic
cross subsidies
that occur
under current net metering tariffs in
place since 2017.
projects are currently being planned and
implemented that count on the
continuation of this inequity through
so the sooner it's corrected the better
the problem with the current
compensation is that it creates a
missing money problem that results in
substantial and i would say ironic undue
cost shifting that did not occur before
2017 with traditional debt metering this
particular change
in how rps compliance costs are
calculated creating the current missing
money or cost shifting problem was not
explicitly recognized by any of the
parties the puc staff or the
commissioners in
de1657
um
you know in which that new iteration of
net metering tariffs were developed um
at that time i represented the city as
both advocate and expert witness and was
actively involved in negotiating two
competing settlement agreements that
actually became the basis for the pucs
order that's referenced in this bill
i'd like to briefly explain you know how
this has changed because it helps to
understand um the nature of this problem
um
each electricity supplier including the
utility default service has an rps
compliance obligation based on the
amount of electricity delivered over the
course of the year to their customers
currently wrecks need to be procured and
retired or alternative compliance
payments made equal to about 25 percent
of the power produced or supplied
in traditional net metering which
sometimes called 1.0 when customer
generator exports to the grid in in
effect turns the meter backwards so that
power exported to the grid carries
forward as a kwh credit to be used to
offset future kwh consumption with pve
often from summer to winter
so a customer that gets about um and you
can use any number here but say gets a
thousand megawatts hour
of power delivered to them over the
course of the year but over that same
year might export 500 megawatt hours to
the grid
um ends up consuming and paying for a
net of 500 megawatt hours
their suppliers rps compliance
obligation under this kilowatt hour
crediting system is actually just based
on the net 500 megawatt hours
um which the customers already paid the
full rate for so it includes their share
of rps compliance so there's no cost
shifting problem here
under the new tariffs
instead of carrying that negative kwh
credit forward if there's surplus you
know exports to the grid in any given
monthly billing cycle it gets monetized
and paid the full default service rate
credit
the problem is when the customer or
or members of a group in group net
metering turn around and receive that
power
that is counted towards the rps
compliance obligation so in the same
example the rps compliance obligation is
a thousand megawatt hours instead of 500
and because you've given full uh credit
for 500 of those there's there's no
revenue from that customer
or that customer generator
to pay for the additional 500 megawatt
hours of rps compliance obligation
so that creates a cost shift that other
customers have to pick up
and again this this was not com
contemplated back in 2017 although there
was a sense
in all the settlement discussions that
prop maybe full default service rate is
maybe over compensation more than what
it should be but that other things like
no credit for transmission were under
compensation so it was felt and the
utilities actually agreed all agreed to
this at the time that it was a rough
justice that it was fair but without
thinking about this particular problem
and and so i just want to give a very
specific example um involving the city
of lebanon about how this actually could
play out in this one to five megawatt
range which i might add you know the
commission's order and those settlements
never contemplated it will apply to the
one to five megawatts so you're talking
about much larger scale of impact so
just as an example the city last month
entered into a interconnection agreement
with liberty in which we're going to pay
over half a million dollars for
distribution and actually some
transmission system upgrades so we could
interco connect five megawatts i mean
five 200 kw micro turbines there will be
one megawatt installation of landfill
gas to energy
so that's going to produce about 8 000
megawatt hours a year
which we can um
and that equals 8 000 renewable energy
credits or wrecks or certificates worth
about 35 each in today's market
generating value to the city of over a
quarter million dollars a year
um
this is roughly equivalent to about six
to seven megawatts of solar pv or about
or maybe 303 megawatts or so of hydro
um in addition to the wreck revenue
those 8 000 megawatt hours
exported the grid in a group net
metering arrangement at current rates of
around 10 cents per kilowatt hour would
generate another 800 000 in revenue to
the city that can be used dollar for
dollar to offset the same amount of
power
supply costs for group members so the
utility under that default energy
service would still have an rps
compliance obligation for some 8 000
megawatt hours delivered to group
members but no revenue from that group
or the host to pay for those compliance
costs shifting all of those costs to
other rate payers who aren't directly
participating in net metering and this
number is actually readily noble every
time the puc approves default service
rates um part of that calculation
there's a line here this is just the
sheet from the from their um
proceeding that specifies what that
number is so today for liberty that's
about um
0.68 cents per kilowatt hour and it's a
little higher about point seven seven
cents per kilowatt hour um uh for
eversource
so that eight thousand megawatt hours
works out to about fifty five to sixty
one thousand dollars in rps compliance
costs from which there's no revenue from
from
the the people for whom that power
supplied to pay for those costs so those
are the costs that would be shifted in
this kind of scale of of one to five
megawatt projects
and i think the irony is
you know in our case the city can
benefit from selling those wrecks for
its generation earning a quarter million
dollars a year while paying nothing for
its own rps compliance cost and that of
its remaining group members
and
even though in theory selling those
wrecks means you are assigning the
renewable attribute
of that generation to others there's
just an irresistible tendency for the
city and other
municipalities to say that we are
offsetting some or all of our load with
group net metered pv or in our case
landfill gas while paying nothing
actually for rps compliance
and of course i'm assuming that
municipalities are not otherwise
exempted from rps compliance obligations
up which is an exemption the city
doesn't support
i did say that this would eliminate one
of two substantial cross subsidies that
i think are problematic you've heard me
talk about the other one and that
regards transmission costs i won't go
into detail on that but but just to come
complete this example
liberty and its customers pay for
transmission
uh based on our share of the monthly
hour of coincident peak demand measured
by an actual meter at the interface
between the transmission grid and the
distribution grid
for some reason eversource doesn't have
meters in that location so i don't
understand how they do it but in any
case with liberty it's clear cut and
they've agreed that if we're exporting
850 kw of power to the distribution grid
at the hour of coincident peak demand it
will lower transmission costs
if we did that on average over the
course of the year which we can do
because we're we'll run like a base load
plant
that is worth some over 125 000 a year
in reduced
transmission cost but we would not
receive any credit for that
but it does actually result in savings
that other customers benefit from so you
could say
between the two there's a trade-off
but that being said i think it's still
worth you know so i do propose an
amendment um in in the text it's in red
on the last page
to just add um a provision and that and
by no later than december 31st 2024
which gives almost two years from now
the commission shall determine through
an adjudicated proceeding an equitable
mechanism for giving credit for actual
avoided transmission charges caused by
such customer generators
um
you know i think if you hadn't kept them
up please yeah if you had an amendment
like that i think it would gender more
bipartisan bicameral support but even if
you don't a minute i think it's worth
sending to the senate because quite
honestly i've tried for the past three
years to get senators up to speed on
this problem with limited success and so
i think it would be worth
presenting that issue for the senators
to understand because i don't think they
really understand it with what they did
last year in expanding that metering so
i'll stop there thank you thank you miss
bill uh
i'll the chair will indulge in asking a
question first i think you hit on part
of the question i was going to ask you
that if we were to pass this bill
two things uh it could be looked at
still by the senate and the and i we've
heard testimony that said that the puc
docket uh should be coming out this
spring so there would be time for the
senate to decide whether or not
uh whatever the puc says but also would
this also send a quiz message to the puc
uh on the intent of the legislation uh
to help them in in their docket
i i think it would um one of the subtle
things here is that the reference to the
order in statute part of that order says
that if you um interconnect under these
net metering 2.0 tariffs you are
grandfathered till 2040
and we won't change those rates so to
the extent we revise rates going forward
it'd only be applicable to new projects
so so that's sort of why this is a
concern is because of that grant
grandfathering position that the
commission would
by sort of its own word uh wouldn't
go back and i think everybody's
expectations you know from the
legislature wouldn't go back and change
these terms unless they had guidance
from
the legislature that that would be
appropriate to do
i mean they'll change them in the next
iteration but that could be a year or
two out
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman
so uh
from what you just said then would that
address the concerns of the hydro
association that just spoke about
changes in contracts they've already
entered into with customers based on
the rps being included
i'm i'm not sure
would what address that
i thought what you were saying is that
the public utilities commission would
likely not
retrofit
oh be retro you know retroactive um i i
think that would would help to clarify
that legislation that maybe this only
applies
to to to projects that um
are somehow new after the data passage
of the bill um so that
somebody who's gone under the current
statute wouldn't
be disturbed you know that that might be
reasonable or adding the
promise of looking at an equitable
transmission credit might also uh be a
way to balance that
thank you i appreciate that
and
just one follow-up and so
the references earlier to the fact that
new was a little ambiguous in terms of
what it referred to in this bill do you
think that that's another piece that
might need to be
specified in order for it to achieve its
objective
um right when i was looking at this with
our city manager and mayor and energy
committee
i said i can't really tell whether this
would apply to our landfill gas project
um
because
well we're right at that one megawatt
threshold um
um
and um
we now have an agree an interconnection
agreement so from certain purposes of
the puc were already in the queue
and um
current
tariffs would apply
um
because that was sort of the basis of
which to cut things off on the other
hand we will be new the thing isn't
constructed yet um
so so that isn't real clear and also
just sitting here reading this the
strikeout of applicable to large
customers
that could be slightly problematic in
that the provisions of that order
only
apply
to
up to one megawatt there's nothing in
that order that would apply to greater
than one megawatt the language and
current law that's being stricken out
says you're going to apply what was
applied to large customer generators the
100 kw to one megawatt will apply to
these new one to five megawatt projects
um so it did just occur to me that
that that that there may be an issue
there i'm not sure
thank you
representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question i have an observation as
well
the question is uh
even though the current bill doesn't uh
have say anything about avoided
transmission the puc is absolutely free
to do that as a result of its docket
right i do think that that is definitely
part of the value of der that is being
that's part of the study that everyone
agreed should be looked at yes my
observation is to thank you very much
for your written testimony and i
encourage it in the future because i can
only capture 10 of what you say right
and i think i think everything was in my
written testimony except for a little
bit of ad-libbing so hopefully
yes before we move on i it's
11 o'clock and i think
i'm going to
recess this public hearing temporarily
so i can open up
hp 1629
hb 1629 is open for public hearing and
i'm recessing 1629 until the completion
of the public hearing
i stand corrected i
you know what the word assume means
so
i thought we were running short on time
in fact we had plenty of time so my part
my apologies please go ahead
representative uh
sampson with your question we are still
in public hearing for the current bill
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
bilo
um
according to your own testimony um
you mentioned that this rps compliance
cost
was assessed in 2017
with the understanding that
as you mentioned before
there were some factors that were
not considered and may be beneficial
others that may be undervalued or
overvalued and this was considered to be
kind of a compromise right
and in your own uh financial example you
used for your city of lebanon you
mentioned that you could actually
determine that you would be creating a
transmission reduction cost for liberty
utility yes and in in net if i'm
not mistaken and hearing what you said
in net you're actually giving a benefit
to every other customer without any
compensation right so with all this
stuff going on
wouldn't you think it would be better
for us not to act on this bill right now
because of the puc docket that we're
waiting for uh
because you guys made a mistake back in
2017 right so now you're saying before
we have a new study why not make another
mistake is that correct um
[Music]
no i'm not saying let's make another
mistake i'm saying let's fix something
that
nobody intended
you know it dawned on me about six
months later that th this changed and i
went around and talked to people um both
puc staff and other parties
and the utility and and it hadn't really
registered with anybody that's that
the way
that netting twh reduced the calculation
of the compliance obligation and
monetizing dinnet that just wasn't on
anyone's radar screen so
um
but but because of the protracted
you know
the idea of the the value of the er
study came out of those settlements and
was part of that order and and it's just
taken a long time to to get it this far
um and and quite honestly i'm not even
sure this specific little piece was
actually is actually part of that study
although it'll be subsumed within the
question of
is full default service rate uh
credit appropriate or not so i think it
will be addressed
uh yeah and follow-up question uh the
in light of
this
um do you see any disadvantage for the
legislature getting ahead of this and
passing something now before that comes
out versus waiting until comes out and
then passing a law maybe is there any
pro or con for this well personally i
think yes because um
there could be a lot of projects that
get developed and locked in between now
and when the commission actually makes a
new decision
and and that would be locking in this
inequity um which i'm just uncomfortable
and the city you know i i didn't make
this decision to support this on my own
um you know it's with the support of the
city um
it just doesn't seem right i mean i mean
we have we have ambitions to put in a
lot more
um
larger pv pv and storage
we quite honestly prefer to do it under
the limited producers approach rather
than net metering because at this kind
of scale it's not
personally you know as the person who
sponsored the first bill that created
net metering with jeb bradley way back
in 1996
um 97
i never imagined that net metering would
be getting used for the scale projects
um it yeah so that that's just a whole
nother story thank you very much
representative kelly pitts question
please
thank you cliff i'm almost afraid to ask
um
having been with you all those years
can you give me a concrete
explanation
or
figures and not all the convoluted ones
what would this actually mean
to your town
so
you have an electric bill now
passage of this bill
which
in your words is the right thing to do
what would it mean as far as an expense
for your town
um
well
if if it applied to our landfill gas to
energy project and i'm not sure it would
um
then it would reduce our compensation by
on the order of seven percent
which our project would still be viable
with that reduction and i i say mike
right now we're approved for one
megawatt interconnection we we do
anticipate um
some some landfill expansion that could
we may want to add another 200 kw
turbine in which case we would be thrown
into this larger group net metering
situation um
and
in that event
you know if this bill passed it would
apply to the entirety of the project
so so we we we would lose revenue from
that element
um
but on the other hand we're getting a
lot of money from selling the wrecks
potentially from the project so it just
only seems right that we should pay for
our rps compliance obligation um for for
the power that does end up getting
delivered to us and our group members
follow-up
cliff without
without
disclosing any
major secrets can you quantify that for
me seven percent would be
what we're talking about that's that
well it's right here it's um about 60
000 a year
and that's sixty thousand dollar may i
it's good that's sixty thousand dollars
a year
from i don't know how many customers
would be involved say that's around the
average
is that enough
to lower
electric rates
in general well
it just it adds up because if that's
this one project you had a bunch of
other projects and realized that this is
for the next 18 years
eventually it's real money
thank you
see
representative partial question please
thanks so much chair
um i understand uh the in principle how
this is a
bill that you know provides some equity
and uh support for the uh rps
but um i'm so concerned because this was
a lot of this came about as you said
and we've grown quite a bit and these
loopholes have grown quite a bit since
then
i can
understand where this is you know
you've benefited from this but as far as
having your transmission charges uh
you know avoided interesting charges
that's another big part that's another
big loophole right there yeah question
there's quite a few i mean i'm just
trying to get a background see if i
understand this
and so the question is is that
is this bill without your amendment to
piecemeal and addressing the situation
and you consider the amendment to be
necessary
to
balancing out the uh
if nothing else the finances on this
bill
um
well if this committee passed this
without the amendment i would advocate
for the amendment over in the senate and
quite honestly i think it's unlikely the
senate would pass this bill
without an amendment or whether they
pass it at all but i think it's worth
taking the time to educate the senators
on the energy committee about this issue
and problem so they so they understand
it better quite honestly
thank you for the follow-up
representative
pimento
thank you mr chairman uh unlike the
chair i only understood about three
percent
of what you said fair enough um
my
question is
about
well the first question is
are you privy to what is going on now in
the docket that we're referring to
um yeah so the city is still a active
intervener and party in that docket yes
and a follow-up mr trump
the the follow-up is that
i mean we're talking about a couple of
things here what's in this bill
and you brought up
another part where it basically goes the
other way which of course i don't
understand
why not
make the docket aware of this
and have them
[Music]
roll all of this into whatever it is
their final decision
is going to be
i i think this issue will be provoked
when this gets
my guess is that after this study is
complete and
the department of energy convenes
stakeholders to review it that somebody
probably the department will petition
the commission to
probably in the same docket
to
issue an order of notice to to begin the
process of
considering proposals for net metering
3.0
you know what what the tariffs will be
going forward because that's always what
was contemplated in the order that's
referenced here
which was always recognized as an sort
of interim step because there was just
too many data gaps to be able to make uh
informed
decisions in an adjudicated context
one go ahead
thank you mr chairman so
getting back to
something that's already been asked
knowing all of that
you still feel that
we should go forward with this bill
with amendment
as opposed to just waiting for what will
happen out of this docket
yes i think that would be worthwhile
because it kind of
begins to straighten out two things that
i think are
sort of you know obvious problems and
and and that the suggestion of giving
the commission until december 31st of
um would would allow them to to proceed
under that docket with that adjudication
that that would be more time than was
originally given to the commission to to
do what they did
which was a pretty
which was a very robust um uh a
proceeding at the time
so i don't think it was rushed but but
this actually gives even more time for
the commission to sort that out and
would allow them to apply it um to these
projects that that you know already are
kind of in the pipeline but before they
set something for new projects going
forward that what was contemplated in
that order all along is
that um if you're in the interconnection
queue before you know in that order was
i forget what it was like a certain date
in september even though the order was
in june if you were in the
interconnection queue by that date you
could be grandfathered under the
original net metering and if you got an
interconnection queue
after that date you would be subject to
the new net metering tariffs and and the
way it was also written you can always
go to the new tariff but you can't go
back to the old tariff once you leave
the original tariff so i'm personally on
net metering 1.0 i could switch to 2.0
it would actually be financially
advantageous for me to do that but but
i've have haven't bothered um
and um
and so one you know one option if
nothing happens and these two things are
adjusted and other things are adjusted
it may be that projects actually want to
move from 2.0 to 3.0 or not you know
remains to be seen um but the idea would
be you can't go back and and once you're
once you've gotten an approved thing
because it is important to the market
and to the parties to have some
certainty as to what the deal is because
just people are making major investment
decisions based on those deal terms i
think it is reasonable to to have this
kind of grandfathering mechanism
and but it's precisely because of that
why i think it would be better to
straighten this out sooner than later
and not let
tens and 20s and 30s megawatts of new
new generation get locked into something
that really
isn't right doesn't feel right on the
face of it
i'm beginning to hear
redundant answers to questions
representative mcgee if you have a
completely new and different and
improved question please
that's a very high bar
representative thomas thank you
actually
for the benefit of the committee i was
hoping that you could go back
to the original explanation that you
gave us
for
my my understanding is that what you're
saying is that we are currently uh
securing a credit that we shouldn't be
securing
uh because of the way the original deal
was structured that we're trying to
eliminate which i wish that was in the
original
testimony to to make us understand sort
of what this is solving for
um
and i think that it may not be clear
here so i i was just wondering if you
could
you could reiterate um
the point that you're making about that
not double dipping but you know the the
fact that it's being credited credited
in multiple places and so it's not
actually accurate um
yeah so i think it is sort of double
possibly triple dipping
which is which is the thing that bothers
me in good conscience you you've got the
renewable advocates and the
municipalities saying we want more of
these renewables but they're saying
we're not going to pay for any of the ar
and we support the rps but we don't
we're not going to pay for any of the
rps compliance costs and we're going to
shift that to other customers now those
do i do think those other customers
benefit in other ways like lower
transmission costs from what they'd
otherwise be
you know how much solar does that really
depends because some solar if it's east
phasing probably doesn't do anything
other solar if it's more west facing and
hits those afternoon summer peaks
you know can provide significant value
but there's you know
but because we don't separately value
that there's no sort of price signal for
new projects to recognize that they may
or may not produce this value because
there's we're saying all kilowatt hours
are are the same and that's not really
true yeah
thank you i think we hit the limit uh on
this bill
uh thank you
the honorable
and i will ask representative pemtel to
give us the blue sheet and the online
results
there are four
nine names on the uh
sheet opposing oh excuse me yes opposing
hp 1599
and
the remote testimony
two people support
opposed
thank you representative uh with that
being said
uh representative clay pitts before i
close the public hearing do you have a
question yes i'd like to ask the
question in the public hearing
uh of the chair
having heard about the possible
um
culmination of this study
in the spring
can we ask the powers to be to provide
the committee with an update
perhaps in late april
and update you say power should be
updated from the pucc
and the and department of energy says i
will just cover all umbrellas on
the status
of that study at that point not
necessarily the details
but the status because i don't want it
to get away for 10 years
i don't see why not we can certainly ask
him to give us an update status
certainly absolutely
probably desirable yeah
with that being said
public hearing is closed on
1599.
and i guess being a victim i apologize
for being a victim of my own uh
efficiency but uh i guess we have an
extended lunch break until one o'clock
where we'll open up the next uh
bill
okay good afternoon everyone time to
resume the
sdna meeting for
february 8th
and we have three public hearings to
go through this afternoon the first one
we'll start here momentarily
before we start i would just like to
remind everybody that if you want to
speak on
any of the bills that we'll be hearing
this afternoon
you need to fill out a pink card and
pass it along forward so that i have it
in front of me in order for you to be
able to
bless you make a contribution
before the committee
so the first bill that we'll hear this
afternoon is house bill 1629-f
n
which is relative to default service for
net energy media metering
and
i will introduce the prime sponsor of
the bill representative berezne
thank you chairman vos members of the
stne committee thank you for the
opportunity to introduce hb 1629 fm
relative to default service for net
metering
this bill aims to bring the net energy
metering section of chapter 362 a
limited electrical energy productions
act in line with the declared purpose of
the chapter specifically the declaration
of purpose contains a finding that quote
the goals of this chapter should be
pursued in a competitive environment
we'll come back to that in a second
net metering is when an electricity
distributor is required to purchase
excess electricity from their customer
the rate at which the distributor must
buy this electricity is currently the
same as the rate at which it sells
electricity to other customers
this requirement to buy and sell
electricity at the same price
means that the distributor is not able
to recoup overhead costs of facilitating
the transfer
when you are forced to buy and sell
something at the same price it is not a
competitive environment
of course there is no magic here this
missing overhead is recouped by raising
electricity rates for everyone else
hb 1629 simply adds the missing
definition for calculating the rate so
that when an electricity distributor is
buying from their customer they are they
are able to subtract their overhead
by allowing the distributor to recoup
their overhead it levels the playing
field and creates a more competitive
environment
furthermore this has the added benefit
of keeping electricity rates lower
fairness in a competitive market is
important for electricity distributors
and keeping electricity rates low is
important for electric customers and
constituents for these two reasons i
urge you to support this bill
and from listening uh to earlier
testimony and other bills there were a
couple of recurring things that came up
that i wanted to point out
as it relates to this bill the first one
is regarding the puc docket on net
metering
i believe that this bill is is more of a
policy change
or a policy
underlining
and so
regardless of how that docket ends i
don't think um
it supersedes this bill
and then the other thing i wanted to
mention is that i've tried getting
information on how the default service
rate is calculated
and it's been rather challenging um
getting getting these details so i think
if this bill passes one of the end
results will also be more transparency
and how um and how that that rate is
calculated i think that that will be
beneficial for
for this committee going forward
and finally if i may i would like to
read part two of the electric utility
restructuring chapter on the purpose
and it says a transition to competitive
markets for the for electricity is
consistent with a directive of part two
article 83 of the new hampshire
constitution which reads in part free
and fair competition in the trades and
industries is an inherent and essential
right of the people and should be
protected against all monopolies and
conspiracies which tend to hinder or
destroy
competitive markets should provide
electricity suppliers with incentives to
operate efficiently and cleanly open
markets for new and improved
technologies provide electricity buyers
and sellers with the appropriate price
signals and improve public confidence in
the electric utility industry
thank you with that i will
conclude my testimony and take any
questions
thank you so we have questions for
representative berezni thank you for
introducing this bill representative
thomas is recognized for a question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question um so in light of the
unbelievably unbelievably high spikes in
electric bills recently
will this bill um
help to have people's electric bills
lowered uh at least by enough to where
they notice it
is this what this will
will help do
i can't guarantee that that will happen
but that is the intent
okay
uh representative plett is recognized
for a question
yes thank you mr chair thank you mr
bharara representative berezni for
taking my question
at first i was puzzled about the
language in this bill but
got it straightened out in my own head
you're excluding
anything from default
service
other than the raw electricity costs
excluding
you're excluding ancillary components of
iso numerous forward and forward
capacity market payments renewable
portfolio standard cost administrative
costs supplier profits and the other
non-electrical energy components as
determined by the commission is that
because
the net net meter
is producing electricity that has no
capacity requirement
at all and
it has no no does not provide any
ancillary service and is that why you're
excluding these costs because they're
not providing that benefit
uh that's correct the the overhead that
the electric uh distributor has is not
the same as the overhead that somebody
producing you know with a few solar
panels on their on their house so it
doesn't make sense that they would have
that they would get paid for that
overhead the same way
okay additional questions for
representative berezni representative
mcgee
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um in looking at the language i'm trying
to figure out how you
came to the conclusion that all of these
ancillary items should be taken out of
the default generation supply cost
i just
don't understand how you arrived at this
conclusion
that this is
going to help with competition
so these these um this list is not
the entire list
at the end here it says and any other
non-electrical energy components as
determined by the commission
the idea is that only
the electrical energy portion of such
supplies should be excluded
the other list are things that i was
able to gather from from what what
things shouldn't be in the list
because because they're not part of the
electrical energy portion
um follow-up
uh thank you mr chairman
and do you have an understanding of why
or how these other components have
become part of the charges that folks
pay
i guess i'm trying to figure out how you
figured out as someone who's relatively
new to this
why these charges should not be included
like what you used to develop that
calculation it's not so much that these
charges shouldn't be included it's that
the the fee should only be based on the
default energy supply
and again why
uh because the net meter because the
person who's producing electricity does
not have uh all of the same uh expenses
as uh distributor
so you're trying to make the distributor
have an eat
an even playing field with a small
producer
that's correct
okay additional questions for
representative
berezni
representative bernardi
thank you chairman uh thank you
regina uh
is uh
is the rate that you're looking at
uh essentially
avoided costs that was described in
the original purple
language that federal statute
is that is that how this is
being
calculated
well i'm not sure i understand your
question
uh
there's a federal law that focused
in on
these types of technologies and they
used
they they require that that the
utilities cover the avoided costs of the
producers so it's their uh
um
they still have all their overhead no
matter what
and so that's what you seem to be
subtracting out so this is going to
traditional avoided costs is that what
you're looking at
i think so
thank you
continue follow-up
all set uh representative bresny to
follow up on the question that
representative mcgee asked
are you saying in this legislation
that
since customer generators do not
supply firm power
they wouldn't be entitled to forward
capacity market payments
and since they don't
have any administrative costs they
wouldn't be entitled to credits for
administrative costs
since they're not a supplier that earns
profits they wouldn't be entitled to
supplier profits
is what you're saying is that because
these customer generators don't have
these
costs they're not entitled to being
reimbursed for those costs
that's exactly
the goal of the bill yet
okay thank you
further questions for representative
berezni representative callie pitts
thank you representative for taking my
question
have you been contacted by anybody
with a fiscal note because i am
wondering and i'm going to ask you
do you know
[Music]
or have any idea how much cutting out
these costs
would save electrical customers on the
whole
so there is a fiscal note that was
submitted but it was after this was
printed and i believe that the person
speaking after me will have
i think he has copies of the fiscal note
and he may speak to that
follow-up okay thank you
okay
representative mcgee thank you mr
chairman my clarification is in just
reading the language that's here
it looks like it's not defining
the small generator it's defining that
these costs are being taken away from
the default
generation supply so that would be a
very different kettle fish
as to what we are saying here is
does anybody else read it that way
the way i read it is that for the
purposes of this section which is a
section that defines how
customer generators will be compensated
and credited
that
since
default service rate is mentioned
several times in the statute as being
the compensation mechanism for
net metering customers
that this definition of
default service would apply
for
this section meaning this part of the
statute
okay and that metering statute thank you
that makes sense okay representative
samsit has a question
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
mr
uh representative for taking my call um
my my question
um
i think maybe the question was asked
before uh
what what percentage or
if you take the current default rate
and you take out all these things that
you mentioned here
um
how much what percentage of the costs
would be cut i mean are we talking one
percent two percent fifty percent i mean
how dramatic a change it would this be
uh it would be
uh almost half almost half but i don't i
don't have i have to do the math dude
yeah i understand i'm not looking for an
exact number but you're saying almost
half
um
so one thing that i had difficulty with
is finding out this information because
it's not defined anywhere and and it's
you know i understand proprietary to
each distributor but
um
could you speak a little bit louder
please okay so it was difficult to get
this as i uh i said in my testimony that
uh it was very difficult to find out in
detailed information about the rate um
and and perhaps part of this you know
one of the end results of this bill is
that uh we will know that
because that you know you'll be you'll
be necessary to provide that in order to
to execute
um but
yeah
okay
well just one follow-up follow-up
i assume that you're aware that some of
these costs that are mentioned here
are involved in
trying to ensure a stable supply of
energy and a reliable and non-volatile
supply of energy to the system
so you know it's not like these things
are being thrown in there for no purpose
um they tend to
help
dispel some of the volatility in these
rates by ensuring for example the former
forward capacity market that there's
something there when you need it i mean
are you aware of the implications of
some of these
charges that why they're there i think
if if those expenses are incurred they
should definitely be reimbursed but
the the the issue is when they're
reimbursed without incurring those costs
okay thank you
okay further questions for
representative berezni
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative berezni for taking my
question
we've had several discussions today
about net metering and the state of net
metering in terms of the docket at the
puc for the value of net metering
and i think that what is
the the aim of this bill seems to be in
you know
further defining the rate setting and
how it would be appropriate to go
forward but there is an effort underway
right now in the rate setting agency
that's defined by the legislature to
take care of this and to look at it
deeply so i'm wondering whether
whether this may be i hate to say
premature since we've been using that so
much lately but but whether this is sort
of um jumping the gun on what is
currently underway
which has been a multi-year review uh of
how this should be valued so
these default rates and how they're
defined would be part of that review
and i just wonder if you could comment
on that because this this seems to be
sort of
um
it's tangential to what the state has
already undertaken for trying to define
how this should be done
i did i did cover that in my testimony a
little bit
um
so
my my perspective on this is that this
this is a sort of enshrining policy that
should already exist
and i don't think it will conflict with
uh any puc decision
um
did you need a follow-up well
i have i mean my thinking is that if the
puc is in the midst of trying to figure
out how to assess this then it would
definitely have an effect on them if we
change the law
telling them what they could and could
not consider so
sorry the language in the bill says and
any other electrical energy components
as determined by the commission so they
uh it is still up to the commission to
determine the final rate
okay so
additional questions for representative
berezni
representative callie pitts
i'm trying to figure out how to wear
this would default service rates or do
you know if default service rates
for the regular customer who's not a net
meter or a medium nearing person
that these things are included in the
calculation of the default service
my understanding is that they they are
follow-up follow-up
so if i am net metering
and 50 of my output
is sold back
and the other 50
is not
will some
of these
charges
that are currently in default service
be applicable to me
on the portion of the electricity that i
do not
send back to the grid
yeah are you talking about the overhead
charges
all of the charges that are included the
ones you want to exclude
oh may i
yes you're the one you're still
answering the questions the wins you the
ones you wish to exclude would they be
included in the
default rate
of the service that i'm not selling to
the grid or that i'm not giving back or
that i'm not not metering because i'm
going to be a consumer
of a portion of the electricity
i i would assume that it would be the
same for what you sell back versus what
you are you saying that
well if you're not selling it then i
guess i'm not really sure i understand
um
are you saying do you get something
well if
if i knit we're not going to have a
discussion no let's not have it okay so
i think
what representative
callie pitts is asking you is
should
you pay the full default service rate
for power that you buy from the utility
and of course the answer to that is yes
that that's what
your rate would be
so she's asking you
if
the portion that they
that the customer generator sells to the
utility
should that also
be credited at the default service rate
i thought it was the part that you okay
um
so um
it should not be credited as the default
service rate because that's i mean
that's the point of the bill
i thought that she was asking about the
part that you keep
not the part that you sell to the um
okay she's nodding her head that's just
what she was asking but i don't
understand how how that part would work
if you're not selling it then there's no
um
it's just electricity you buy correct so
you pay the price for it right
okay additional questions for
representative brezhney
seeing none
well thank you for introducing this bill
and we'll move on to the next
presenter
who will be griffin roberge from the new
hampshire department of energy
so
thank you chairman vos members of the
committee for the record griffin roberge
from the
new hampshire department of energy uh
department takes a neutral position on
this bill but obviously wanted to
provide observations as we always do um
what was it uh i did pass around a copy
of the fiscal note that was generated by
the department you'll note that it was
revised as of
february 2nd so i understand some
members of the committee might not have
had a chance to review it as
representative kelly pitts mentioned
so
i just wanted to give everybody a chance
to have a copy of that for their review
i did have some discussions with the
prime sponsor of this bill last week and
i very much appreciated the opportunity
to talk with him get a sense as to
what his aim was what for the bill and
everything like that
he did ask me some questions and i will
follow up with him offline to get him
answers to those questions and obviously
if the committee has any questions feel
free to ask and i i might not have the
answer but i can certainly follow up um
regarding the language in this bill
obviously it defines default generation
supply service
as the electrical energy portion of
generation supply
and excludes uh other certain components
such as iso forward capacity market
payments rps compliance cost
administrative costs etc etc um
after talking uh with other staff
members at doe as well as you'll see
outlined in the fiscal note the fiscal
note has a little bit more clarification
as to the obviously fiscal impact of
this bill but um
one of the main concerns i think the
department wanted to raise is that it
could be
near impossible to exclude some of the
costs that are noted in this bill from
net metering tariffs
default service providers
obviously go out to bid for the power
that they provide but the costs for that
are not broken out by forward capacity
payments administrative costs supplier
profits
requiring bidders to disclose the
various aspects of these costs would at
best potentially
slow down
default service biddings and auctions
and at worst again at worst could
potentially lead to failed default
service auctions
again as the
committee is certainly well aware by
this point the department is hiring a
con has hired a consultant and is
working on a
value of distributed energy
uh resources study that is expected to
be out in late spring of this year
again that study will give a very
uh
solid overview as to where
the value of these resources going
forward what's been done to date
potential cost impacts and that type of
thing
so
this bill along with a couple of other
net metering related bills might be
premature at this time pending the
outcome of that study
and with that i'm certainly willing to
answer any questions but
can certainly follow up with people
offline if i don't have the answer for
you today thank you
thank you
mr roberge for your
testimony on this bill
is it not true that
the commission
requests proprietary information from
utilities and other sources
on a routine basis and keeps that
information confidential that's correct
in uh to further follow up on that i
think that's what i would i didn't say
it explicitly but um
that's one of the concerns i guess when
it comes into the bidding process is
some of this information again is
proprietary and
requiring that to maybe be disclosed to
break down
costs for net metering tariffs might be
problematic during that bidding process
would it be your judgment that this bill
requires that information to be
disclosed in order for the commission to
come up with a tariff for default
service i think i think it would yes
okay additional questions representative
plett
you're saying this could not be kept in
camera that's a legal term which
yeah
that would have to be it cannot be kept
in camera it would have to be disclosed
why i i apologize did you say in camera
yeah sorry i'm sorry i'm not familiar
with the term i apologize it's a legal
term but i'm not a lawyer okay
but i i rubbed no shoulders with
attorneys all around me for my career no
that's what i'm just doing i mean i am
certainly not an attorney by any stretch
of the imagination for sure i can
certainly offer you a more extensive
answer but i know when it comes to
auctions and bidding process and that
type of thing
some costs including some of those
outlined in the bill are proprietary and
tend to be
obviously confidential requiring some
level of disclosure those costs for the
purpose of defining these costs for the
for the
net metering tariff might be a bit
problematic couldn't the utility supply
a net cost which essentially avoided
cost avoiding all these other excluding
all these other things
and not disclose the breakdown except to
the puc and in camera i mean
it could but what that what that does to
the length of the bidding process for
default service auctions i couldn't
predict but at best again it might slow
it down a little bit
and how that impacts utilities and that
type of thing i'm sure they could speak
to that in greater detail
okay additional questions for mr roberge
representative sausage
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
rubbish for taking my question
i notice in a fiscal note
you do mention that um
uh this bill could has the potential
for reducing the cost uh
uh
per kilowatt hour forgive me i'm sorry
what paragraph are you looking at i
apologize i'm looking at the fiscal note
you gave us yes yes
in that fiscal note um
you mentioned that um
bill appears to reduce the per kilowatt
hour credit provided
if a county or a local government
participates blah blah blah it has the
potential for reducing those costs
but at the same time on the second part
second page of the fiscal note says
there is the potential that net metering
distributed generation may reduce
transmission costs and avoid other
utility costs which would reduce or
otherwise mitigate the impact of the
cost increases
so i assume what you're saying here is
there is some ambiguity whether
not reducing the one cost
uh may may actually
uh result in some other costs being
higher and therefore
uh mitigating
the impact of any of the decrease
is that what your intention was to say
here or what can you explain that
further sure and if if you'll allow me
it's going to be a little awkward just
give me just a second just to read the
paragraph again one more time here
sure so uh forgive me so that
second paragraph on the first page of
the fiscal note obviously the bill is um
defining the default service rate for
the purposes of these tariffs to include
the electrical energy portion of that
supply but exclude these other costs so
in essence it's lowering the cost of the
of the tariff that's given to those who
net meter and export to the grid um so
in essence you would in that paragraph
have a decreased in electrical costs but
the department did also note that
um
a reduction in the credit provided for
these exports you know would tend to
reduce electric rates you know in terms
and also decreasing electrical costs for
consumers but as you mentioned you know
distributed energy uh generation does
have the potential to
reduce transmission costs and avoid
other utility costs so to the extent
that
this credit may disincentivize or
incentivize further renewable energy
projects in the states and customer
generators you know that's something
that the department noted we can't give
any specific numbers or anything like
that it's hard to it's hard to figure
but
circling back to what i had said
initially is that again the department
is working with a consultant to study
these issues so to look at this more
holistically in a study rather than a
kind of a piecemeal approach if you will
thank you very much thank you
further questions for mr roberge
representative oxenoum
thank you mr chair thank you mr roberge
we heard this morning from mr cliff
below that there's uh net metering was
rough justice that you know your
the entire system benefits from avoided
transmission costs
but for the 2.0 customers which are a
subset
there is this missing money issue
and that to a certain extent they cancel
each other out
you you've raised some other issues
i i think this really goes
and i know this has to be a question but
for for clarity's purposes
you you
is it not the case
that this is why we have professional
regulators who understand the
complexities of tariff
and why the doe hired a consultant so
that all of these there are many
interacting components some go take it
up some take it down
to try to pick out one element or as
this one does to cut in half the default
service rate um
i think i think
i think what you suggested was that it
was premature did i i think i heard i
believe i said that yeah so um
is that your question
that was the clarification i was looking
for so thank you very much i i have i
have a further question but i think it's
better for the utilities we so often
hear that these changes that we suggest
make difficulties for the utilities in
their
ability to assign rates that things are
done by hand they're not even automated
systems
that we could be increasing the cost in
ways that are entirely outside of this
purview but they are cost to our
utilities which would then be passed on
to
uh customers ratepayers
okay thank you thank you
uh in response to the question i thought
it was going to be a lot more difficult
you're going to ask me to respond to
substantial things that cliff below
mentioned and there's no way you can
manage that uh i wouldn't do that too in
any case uh you know
circling back to how i answered
representative sanchez again you know
the study will will be comprehensive
look at all of these factors and provide
policy makers as well as stakeholders
who are involved in the docker process
as well as state agencies um you know
guidance on you know the value of
distributed energy resources in the
state it's kind of focused solely on you
know new hampshire not what
massachusetts is doing maine is doing
all those other things um
you know obviously we the department you
know takes direction from policymakers
such as yourselves but you know
you know
states want to obviously be sure that
policymakers are fully informed of you
know the the proposals that they bring
forward and
why i'm here today
thank you very much thank you
thank you so representative callie pitts
has a question
all of us on this committee and i i i'm
going to be i'm going to take the
liberty and ex
talk for all of us are concerned about
electricity rates
however
just confirm for me
that all these inclusive things in this
rate in this default service
was approved by the puc after an
extensive docket and formula
compilations would you confirm that this
is not willy-nilly sure but i mean
that's different for every utility in a
different rate case and ever and
everything like that yes
before the puc
okay uh one other question for you your
fiscal note says that state counties and
local governments
are likely to experience decreased
expenditures for electricity due to this
bill
and it also says that
it would in turn decrease electricity
costs for consumers
so the department is
right reasonably sure that this bill
would indeed lower costs for consumers
and
municipal and county governments
yes we recognize the potential for that
because again we're separating out for
the purposes of net metering tariffs for
the default service rate we are at least
as this bill defines it we are defining
that rate as including the electrical
energy portion of that supply but
excluding these other costs so by
excluding those other costs you are in
essence decreasing
the
the default service rate that's included
in the tariff which in essence reduces
the tariff or the credit that's given
the customer generators which in turn
would reduce energy costs a lot of
steps there but yes
okay thanks for clarifying that
all right so you know oh there's one
more representative mcgee a further
clarification did you not also mentioned
that there was a potential for uh
failed default service freight auctions
that i did mention that at the outset
correct
so
so we would be
looking to
lower electric bills at the rate of
destabilizing the system i think i think
again circling back to what
representative flett had mentioned and
i'll certainly like to follow up with
the committee and get more clearly on
the confidentiality of some of these
costs but um requiring a breakdown of
all these costs in default service bids
again at best would prolong the bidding
process at worst could potentially lead
to failed auctions
thank you
okay
seeing no further questions mr roberge
we thank you for testifying
and i would like to call on our next
testifier
who is
joseph kwosnik
of concord representing himself
mr kwosnik
thank you mr sherman thank you to the
committee for allowing me to testify
today
as i testified this morning in the
previous bill i'm a founding member of
the new hampshire network
and former chairman of new hampshire
electric cooperative and a retired
environmental executive in national grid
i am today submitting written cop
testimony in opposition to house bill
1629 my reasons for posing the bill is
as follows
one is the bill seems to exclude with
the exception of the electrical energy
portion of default generation supply
service all of the ancillary components
of supply such as iso forward capacity
market payments
renewable portfolio standard costs
administrative costs supplier costs and
other non-electrical
uh components as determined by the
commission
and i think we as we spoke about this
morning in june of 2017 the puc
established uh net metering tariffs that
are currently in effect these tariffs
were considered appropriate in that they
avoided any unjust or unreasonable cost
shifting between customer classes
the current net metering tariff properly
credits the exportation electricity from
small systems up to 100 kw and includes
the value of default service
transmission 25 percent of distribution
for large systems between 100 kw and 1
megawatt compensation for export is at
the value
of default service only
because the puc is currently studying
the value of distributed energy
resources under the vder program
i want to make sure i don't misspell
misspell that the vder program and will
be expected to make future adjustments
to the net metering credits as necessary
to avoid cost shifting this study is
expected in the spring thus making any
legislative changes premature
it also seems to be
excuse my language a quote unquote a
backdoor to minimize compensation to net
metered
customer generators in new hampshire the
bill essentially mandates compensation
to net metered customer generators at
essentially wholesale rates this is
inappropriate and fails to recognize the
system benefits and value of net
metering and i just make a note that
prior bills in before this this
committee in in prior sessions of the
legislature have tried to actually um
bring down the compensation to metering
two wholesale rates and those have
failed in the past and this is
essentially uh a bill that is trying to
do that
uh the bill
inappropriately interferes with the
current default generation supply
definition including its ancillary
components and prejudges the outcome of
the puc vder study it should not pass
and should be determined to be an
expedient to legislature legislate
thank you very much for the opportunity
i would take questions
okay questions for mr kwasnik
representative mcgee
thank you thank you mr chairman and
thank you mr kwasnik for taking my
question
um i can remember in past sessions that
we've had people come to speak to us
about
uh the value of distributed energy
in other places in the region and i'm
just curious we're not the only state
that's undertaken trying to look at
what the value of these resources are
and i was wondering if you had any
information
of how that's come out in other places
because i know we've seen evidence in
the past
i'm not aware i'm sure there have been
studies in other states within the new
england area because i think they're a
little bit beheaded of us in terms of
the actual implementation of these
regulations and these these laws i do
know that in the state of new hampshire
with my experience with the electric
co-op is that back about five years ago
the question of the value of renewable
energy and net metering came up before
the the board of the new hampshire
electric co-op and the staff at
co-op was
asked to actually consider what the
benefits and costs
to the system were for net metering
and the co-op actually came up with a
number that was slightly different than
the default but very close to it and
their belief staff belief was that the
default rates that are applicable to the
other i o
investor owned utilities in new
hampshire are pretty close to what
what the value of renewable energy and
that metering is in the state so i think
their research and i don't have it in
front of me it was something that's done
five or six years ago was that the the
rates that were that net metering uh
sources get today are pretty fair
for both the customers and for the
generator thank you
thank you representative sausage has a
question
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
kwasnik for being here
um
if if we were to uh
with this bill reduce the the price down
to the wholesale price
as you mentioned
um
are all wholesale
energy units equal
is there no quality difference between
whether i generate
one unit of energy with coal versus one
university with solar
i'm not an expert in the market but a
wholesale price is whatever the market
will is offering
a megawatt hour at and it can vary from
day to day from minute to minute and
from month to month so uh and there may
be some value in some priority payments
for various generation that is of higher
quality such as renewables and things of
that sort well
excuse me follow up follow up well i i
was just
wanting to ask you whether
what are those qualitative differences
do you know
could you comment on what qualitative
differences there might be between one
energy source versus another sure
i do know that in the report
the rps market not just in new hampshire
but in other new england states is that
there is various
payments premium payments paid for what
call higher quality renewables that many
cases have diverted renewables renewable
wrecks from our state to other states
like connecticut such as some of the
um
i think some of the the solar wrecks
have actually been siphoned off from our
state to those other states but yeah
there's some quality difference in terms
of regeneration um but again it's it's
in the market the market makes it makes
a determination of what those rates will
be on a day-to-day and hour-to-hour
basis
okay thank you thank you
thank you uh you mentioned in your
testimony that this bill would tamper
with the definition of the default
service rate that's correct where in
statute is the default service rate
defined
i'm talking about where it's defined in
the rsa
in rsa
362-a semicolon 9 there's a definition
of default service there
and that was i was referring to can can
you point me to that language
um i'd have to go back to my chair but i
think it's right in the opening
paragraph of that rsa
okay thank you representative callie
pitts
there's a couple of uh
words that
over the years to me have been red flag
words
may
could
and
that are not positive and in the
statement from mr roberge we had
one of the red flags
that when we do this it could reduce the
amount of future development of
facilities in other words customer
generators
do you believe that to be true
i i guess i do believe that to be true
if indeed
when you remove all these ancillary
components from the default
generation supply service
and you're getting down close to well
called wholesale rates
many of these
net metered customer generators will
choose not to install these facilities
and also the question is will they tend
to keep will they renew them when their
useful life is up i i think you'll see a
lot of net meeting metering say solar
folks as they get to the end of the life
of their components if they're being
paid at this lower rate they will not
tend to
replace those those systems
so it's the problem of replacement but
also initial installation too will be
much chilled in the state
my view may i follow follow-up
follow-up would be do you believe
that these future developments
could have more value
in them
than the small and i believe it would be
a small amount of money and
i'm not talking about pennies but i'm
not talking about hundreds of millions
either
uh do you believe that these future
developments
could be worth more
than what we may return
now
you're speaking of net metered
generating resources i believe that
this resources such as solar wind and
other renewable sources will become more
valuable in the future especially as we
find that we are going to be carbon
constrained
in the next 10 to 20 years which i think
will
will occur within our economy so those
resources will become much more valuable
the the resources that are more fossil
based
coal which is
almost gone
and also even natural gas even though
it's a lower carbon emitting sources
it's not a zero carbon emitting source
so i think they'll become less valuable
in the future when we get into carbon
constraint economy
representative plett is recognized for a
question thank you mr chairman thank you
for taking my question mr kwasnik
20 years ago the wholesale market was
created we had the re-regulation uh
generations split off from
uh the utilities
and it was a competitive market
and ever since then i've seen
states undermining that market with
subsidies for this and that and aren't
these subsidies it was a generator in
the open market for electricity gets
paid
locational marginal price essentially
the raw energy price period now they get
paid for other things or they provide
other services but by providing more
than that to customer generators are we
slowly undermining that market
i think we should be very careful when
we start to talk about subsidies to
these particular sources because if you
go back into the supply chain whether
it's a gas or oil or even coal
there are subsidized subsidizations in
those
producing processes so
i'm not prepared today to really say
what's the right balance but it's it's
you would have to tease out all the
subsidies that are in the supply chain
for all these various resources
okay
we thank you you've had your two
questions
and we have to move on because we have
several more people and we're running
out of time
so
thank you mr kwasnik for your testimony
and i would now call on ian oxenom
who is representing himself from
plainfield new hampshire
and i'll alert
representative oxendine that it might be
a conflict of interest for you to ask
questions of this
testifier
of my legislative assistant
thank you
please turn on the mic
okay
i'm ian oxum
i'm a licensed new hampshire attorney i
also have a degree in math and energy
regulation and law and this is an area i
practiced and i wanted to submit some
testimony to
correct what i feel are some faulty
factual premises this bill is based on
as the
i go into more detail in my written
testimony but in the interest of time
i'll probably just try to be a bit more
brief in what i have here
my
first thing i really want to make
clear is that when a net meter generator
exports energy to the vocal distribution
system
they are avoiding far more than just the
raw electricity costs the idea that
there are not avoided capacity costs or
avoided ancillary costs
is simply false and there's several
reasons for this one
when a utility arranges to provide
default services customers it goes to
supplier and that supplier bundles that
all into a single per unit price and so
when
and that's usually somewhere around the
range of 8 cents per kilowatt hour when
a customer generator exports energy to
the
distribution grid that reduces on a per
unit basis the amount of energy that
supplier has to deliver and thus for the
utility avoids basically eight cents on
the default service component i'm not
gonna go into distribution and
transmission just individual simplicity
because i think that's also beyond the
scope of this bill
and two these are actually avoid costs
for that supplier as well because iso
any bills the supply of ancillary costs
based on how much
energy gets delivered to that wholesale
meter point and capacity costs are based
on coincident peak demand and i want to
be very clear
that even though solar is not a firm
resource io soleni has been very
carefully has very carefully calculated
the fact that it has reduced
peak the demand speaks sum of demand in
new england by over 800 megawatt
megawatts and it has a reduced capacity
cost and the market simply from that by
at least tens of millions of dollars and
when you factor in how it has suppressed
the craving price on the floor capacity
market solar has probably reduced
capacity costs in the wholesale market
region wide by hundreds of millions of
dollars per year so the idea that solar
exports the grid are only avoiding raw
electricity costs is demonstrably false
from a factual position from a factual
standpoint
and i really want to be clear that most
of these costs that there are including
default service that we that i think the
bill sponsor assumed
uh were not being avoided by solar
exports actually all being avoided by
solar exports to the distribution grid
and i want to make that very clear today
that as a result of this if this bill to
go forward what you would have is a
situation in which the customer
generator is being compensated at a far
less rate than the cost they are
actually avoiding for the utility and
you basically have a situation where the
customer generators will be charged for
default recharge more for their default
service than the cost of actually
providing them with default service on a
net basis and so i would argue that as a
punitive
uh rates that are two customer
generators that do not reflect cost
causation and that's why this bill
should be
these things are inexp valued in the
proceeding we was mentioned
on in the vdo
vder value stack and this study's broken
up they are explicitly looking at the
avoided capacity and avoid ancillary
service costs and we should really let
that process play out to determine what
they are but and as the previous speaker
mentioned
the uh
co-op also found that basically the
avoided costs are pretty close to
default service costs on the angie side
and that's why they're happy to pay that
and this similar thing has happened with
community power aggregations
that the dropped language in the
template for community power templates
how they're going to handle net metering
is they're going to pay the full energy
service rate they don't that does not
include transmission distribution
because that's still handled by the
utilities but the draft language is free
of any legal requirement
they are going to pay the full energy
service weight for exports that they
they charge to the customer generator
because that is a fairly accurate
reflection of the cost they will
actually avoid the community power
aggregations and that is free of any
legal compulsion
and because they do not because they do
not view the subsidy they view that as a
roughly accurate
value for what the customer generator is
exporting and so i believe this bill has
been based on a faulty factual premise
and for that reason should be ruled in
experience of legislate and i go into
more detail in my written testimony
thank you
thank you are you willing to take
questions yes yes i am okay
representative platt has a question
thank you yes i'm aware of isil new
england's practice of adjusting demand
for
the impact of this stuff
but what obligation does any net meter
have to provide at peak time as opposed
to a generator which gets paid for that
service
they do not they do not have an
obligation but they nonetheless provide
the service
they and because as they as i saw he's
calculated solar has reduced as of 2020
it was about 800 megawatt reduction and
if you simply multiply that by the
current place in terms of how much
capacity costs avoided you get about 50
million dollars and i think it's even
more once you factor in how that has
suppressed wholesale cooling prices so
though they have no obligation to do it
they are providing the value of avoiding
uh capacity costs the thing is that from
iso andy's point of view they are they
aren't acting as a supplier they're
acting as a load reducer they're simply
reducing the amount of load the
centralized system has to serve which
means less centralized system less which
means less central generation capacity
has to be procured in order to meet peak
summer demand which creates cost savings
for the entire system and has reduced
capacity costs that everywhere pay a new
grant has paid by tens if not hundreds
of millions of dollars every single year
representative samsic
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr oxnam for being here um so
if i understand your your your
appeal here
correct me if i'm wrong
you're basically saying that
a net meter uh
generator
uh when it provides energy into the grid
this is a load reducer
and therefore being a load reducer the
amount of load it's reducing
that is the avoided cost of the utility
that now doesn't have to provide that
energy
and therefore
they should be equally compensated at
the same rate otherwise the utility
would be making money off of someone
who's generating their own energy is
that correct essentially correct there
is true that on the distribution side it
gets a bit more complicated because the
is still going on the distribution grid
so you can argue the utility is still
including some cost on the distribution
system but it is definitely avoiding
energy and transmission costs
including the energy costs i mean
inclusive of capacity and ancillary
service and also supplier profit because
like i said before
when you export to distribution grid
that kilowatt hour goes to someplace
else on that same distribution grid
which means you've reduced the amount of
the number of kilowatt hours that have
to be imported from the bulk
transmission system which means the
supplier delivers less energy which
means the supplier charges less and that
is how you have a situation where
pretty much the the full default service
cost may be exclusive within the rps
compliance costs
is avoided by that exports the grid and
also due to other reasons of how rps
compliance costs work usually most
exports from that media generators also
avoid rps compliance costs for other
reasons but i don't have time to get
into that today
thank you
okay thank you
representative mcgee has a question yes
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
oxenam for taking my question
um
it sounds to me my summary of what
you're saying is that you're saying this
bill doesn't achieve what it seeks to
achieve because i did ask the sponsor
what he was trying to achieve with this
which was really right-sizing these
costs and uh thinking that he was doing
something to help save people money
and it sounds from your testimony and i
i really appreciate you giving us some
measurable pieces here
that we were able to jot down so that we
have a better understanding but
it sounds to me like what you're saying
is that the bill wouldn't achieve those
ends because it wouldn't it would
it would be quantifying something that
isn't accurate in terms of how the
system's actually operating
i think that that's mostly what i'm
trying to say
more specifically though what i think is
the bill is trying to achieve a the
appropriate level of compensation for
net metering but due to a faulty factual
premise it the sponsor is assuming that
value is far less than it actually is
because and i really
don't blame people for this because
this is something even as a trained
lawyer someone with a specific degree in
this
it takes me a while to figure out
exactly how the money flows who avoids
this and so i'm not all surprised that
this factual mistake was made but i just
wanted to correct it because i think the
goal should be
to compensate uh solar for the costs it
avoids and but and if you're only
compensating it for avoided low energy
costs you are far f compensated far far
less than the cost that is actually
avoided when you're putting an extra
kilowatt hour onto a distribution grid
as opposed to the bulk transmission grid
and so i believe the sponsor was well
intentioned and trying to evaluate
appropriately but he was
operating on a faulty factual premise
thank you okay thank you uh we'd like to
move on we have two more people who
would like to testify we appreciate you
being here mr oxenam thank you for
hearing me
and i would like to call now on kelly
buchanan of clean energy new hampshire
ms buchanan
all right thank you mr chair i have
written testimony for everyone today
all right for the record my name is
kelly buchanan i'm director of
legislative and regulatory affairs at
clean energy new hampshire
and i'm here today before you in strong
opposition of house bill 1629
for a couple of reasons that have
already been discussed so i will be
brief
but as a brief history lesson on the
general court in 2016 passed house bill
which tests the public utilities
commission with developing an
alternative net metering tariff
and so within that docket they took a
look at the tariff and issued an order
in 2017 to set the net metering tariffs
as they currently are and so in
improving these tariffs the puc found
that they were appropriate
and then on top of that the puc is
consid continuing to study
uh the value of distributed energy
resources and will make the appropriate
changes to the alternative net metering
tariff if they find that's necessary and
i want to highlight for the committee
today the importance of the stakeholder
process that's been going on in that
docket
it's one of our larger dockets that
we've been working on and it's been in
effect since 2016.
and for context i was still working on
my undergraduate degree in 2016. so it's
been a while
but we find that this study process
really brings together all the
appropriate information
as well as some really technical and
valuable
resources that the department of energy
has invested in as well as the puc and
so we find that house bill 1629 is
premature and because we expect that
study to be completed so quickly in the
spring we would really urge the
committee to
be patient and to examine that study
which will perhaps enlighten many of the
questions that have been asked here
today
briefly i'll just highlight that we are
also concerned that house bill 1629
would negatively and abruptly impact the
current and future economics of
distributed energy resources in new
hampshire all without taking into
account the information in that study in
the veda study so
finally i'll end with that we find that
it is most appropriate to consider any
changes to tariffs in the regulatory
environment at the public utilities
commission where those matters can be
appropriately adjudicated and brought
before the stakeholders that have been
working on this
for
say six years now quite a long time
so with that i would be happy to take
any of your questions and um thank you
for your time today
thank you ms buchanan before we take any
questions
i'm going to open the public hearing on
house bill 1248
and recess that public hearing until we
complete the current public hearing
now questions for ms buchanan
representative samsich
thank you mr chairman thank you miss
became for being here i was previously i
asked one of the uh
testifiers about
if there is a quality difference between
energy units
generated one way versus another
and it dawned on me from what someone's
mentioned
that
when it comes to solar wrecks uh
renewable energy certificates generated
by solar
the price is different in each of the
states in new england
can you tell me for example what the
price approximately is in new hampshire
versus let's say in connecticut
uh that's an excellent question i don't
have the exact price on top of my head i
know that it is lower in new hampshire
but i would there might be someone
behind me who would know the exact
answer to that
okay would
follow up would you be surprised to if i
told you that i'm pretty sure that it's
five dollars and i'm sure
dollars in connecticut
and that sounds about right from my
experience okay thank you
okay additional questions for ms
buchanan
seeing none i would like to call on the
next uh presenter
for this public hearing we have one
final card and that is
two representatives of the granite state
hydropower association miss kroll and ms
minnow
um good afternoon mr chairman and
members of the committee um again for
the record my name is heidi kroll i work
at gallagher callahan gartrell and i am
representing granite state hydropower
association and with me today is
madeline minnow
with essex hydro which is a gsha member
we are very opposed to
house bill
1629 i submitted written testimony via
email to the committee yesterday and
also passing around written testimony
right now
we agree with a lot of the comments that
have been made here today
you know first of all as you've heard
and you're well aware there's a process
going on at the puc
a lot of stakeholders have been involved
and there was a lot of
consensus and agreement around
the process that would take place
well
while the study was going on
agreeing to the tariffs that are in
place which include default service as a
an appropriate um
credit for excess generation that's put
onto the grid by facilities that are 100
kw or higher
um
i did want to point out in house bill
1116 from 2016
it reads in part it is in the public
interest to continue to provide
reasonable opportunities for electric
customers to invest in and interconnect
customer generator facilities and
receive fair compensation for such
locally produced power while ensuring
costs and benefits are fairly and
transparently allocated among all
customers
when we read this bill as the other
folks have testified we really do see
this as essentially setting the net
metering credit at a wholesale rate or
something close and we do not think that
that would be fair
um fair compensation for the true value
of net metered power that's put onto the
grid
and it's also important to recognize and
madeline will talk about this a little
bit more
if you were to adopt this legislation it
would certainly kill
all efforts that
were put into motion when
house bill 315 was passed last year
allowing for
municipal host generators
so again that's
a group net metering
where
any excess generation put onto the grid
by a generator
is specifically earmarked for a group of
customers
in this case under the law a group of
customers who are either municipal
county
school
any those sorts of governmental type of
entities
and so setting the value when the
generator puts the excess generation
onto the grid which is earmarked for
those consumers
giving them a value of simply wholesale
price
really will kill group net metering in
that situation because there is
uh you know hydro facilities are um
you know in a lot of cases wholesale
prices are barely helping to cover their
costs and there's really no room in
there at all to give savings to the
group members
so
again i'll let madeline speak more but
we really uh are opposed to this bill
because we think that it undermines the
fair compensation um for the the true
value of excess generation put onto the
grid
i'll make a a few points so to add to
that um
a current existing generator would
actually lose money by becoming a group
net metering host if this bill were to
pass compared to being a wholesale
market participant
so uh
they would
they would be
a huge financial disincentive to
participate in groupnet metering being a
groupnet metering host and returning
some of those savings to customers that
would want to participate in groupnet
metering with such a local renewable
host
so um
it's i think important to recognize the
fair value as has been explained by
several of the previous testimonies to
speak to some of the components that are
proposed to be removed here from the net
metering credit
for example capacity
distributed generation and customer
generators i think absolutely deserve
compensation for capacity the sponsor
said that he thought they didn't because
they are not firm power so to be clear
in iso new england the capacity market
is not only open to
what he described as firm power it's
open to all generation all types of
generation renewable intermittent it's
even open to non-generation resources
like demand response and energy
efficiency
so distributed generation either avoids
the capacity
cost so it doesn't have to be paid if
they're acting like a load reducer or if
you're a previous market participant and
had already bid into the capacity
auction your capacity payments are
actually transferred to your host
utility which goes to reducing the cost
of the credit or they're getting the
credit and then they give it to you they
give it back to you and you're net
metering credit so i think that it would
be actually completely unfair to take
that away and a generator that is
somewhat sizable
if they were to participate in the
wholesale market would be getting those
capacity payments and so that's where
that financial disincentive comes in
that they actually
um would not
you know as as heidi said it would kill
something like groupnet metering
which also does have some administrative
costs
to recruit your members to manage your
members you also have to track all of
your members
usage monthly so that you can file a
required annual report so there is some
management and all of that
administrative work and associated cost
is something that the utility doesn't
have to do because in some other states
group net metering or community solar is
managed by the utilities and that's then
a cost of the utility incurs here in new
hampshire the group hosts incur that
typically
so
um there's just to get to some of those
components we agree that at least the
default service all of it compensation
in a rough amount of value
is what would be the fair compensation
for customer generators
okay questions for
these
testifiers i have one for you the
california public utilities commission
just recently
issued a recommendation that
net metering costs be lowered from
retail in california to the wholesale
level
and their reasoning was that
net metering
charges have escalated in california to
the point
where
they were concerned
that
these high electricity costs would
discourage the adoption of electric
vehicles and the adoption of other
electrification
such as heating systems
that could
advance their
net zero goals
they were also extremely concerned about
the fact that
net metering
driving up
electricity costs hurts low income
people the most
do you fear that that kind of thing
could happen in new hampshire if we
don't get firm control over net metering
costs
no not at all um you're talking about a
state that had full retail net metering
credit
with
uh
incredibly high penetration of
solar and other net metered resources
here in new hampshire we're still at an
extremely low penetration
and
since 2017
there are no net metered facilities or
customer generators that are compensated
at full retail
and so
long before we get anywhere near the
penetration of even our neighbors like
vermont or massachusetts
the credit for customer generators is
already significantly below
full retail
therefore we would never get to a point
like californ the situation california
which granted they've had incredible
pushback against that decision
is there concern that high electricity
prices could discourage the adoption of
other electrification
projects such as
a move to electrical electric vehicles
or
electric heating
i mean devices is that a justified
concern if you want to talk about high
electricity prices i'm a unitil customer
here in concord and our default service
rates just went through the roof
and uh that is not due to distributed
energy resources that's due to natural
gas markets so
yeah sure uh you know i have a heat pump
and i'm heating with it and it's pretty
expensive to heat my house this winter
because of
the natural the international natural
gas markets
so
i mean yes but does that have anything
to do with net metering in new hampshire
no
okay thank you additional questions for
i would just add to that mr chairman if
i could that yes go ahead uh thank you
i'll be i'll be brief but i was just
going to say that
you know from our perspective
we believe that
more renewable distributed resources
throughout the grid could actually add
stability and over the long term keep
prices lower
than the volatility that we're seeing in
the markets and and competing on a
national and international basis um
keeping it local
and these are very stable
prices relatively speaking that come
from renewable resources compared with
other
generation sources that we we have right
now
okay thank you additional questions for
these ladies representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
as i listen to you speak
and whenever we get speakers that
actually have extensive experience we
we get a lot of nuance in terms of
what's involved in uh in in pricing and
in the field and what goes into
uh the markets but our committee has a
lot of conversations that revolve around
competition
and what i'm hearing today is that we're
we're kind of mixing apples and oranges
because my understanding is that the
original deregulation was to
help bring competition to the retail
generation markets
and we're talking about
crossing a retail
contributor
with wholesale pricing which is another
a different animal
and so i i wonder if you could say a
little bit about that because
i think it depends on what problem we're
trying to solve and i
i thought what we were looking at was
trying to figure out how to make that
competitive market work the way we would
like it to work
and yet it seems like we're doing
something that's that's not centered
around um
enhancing or diversifying the retail
market when we're talking about applying
wholesale rates which is really a
different kettle of fish
i know it's a long question
you're absolutely right i mean the
electric industry restructuring statute
um talks about competition at both the
wholesale and the retail levels and you
know we've as a region have done a lot
of work and there's been a lot of
advancements in getting a very robust
wholesale competitive market but there's
still a lot to be done at the retail
level in making sure the consumers
really do have
choices and competitive options and
frankly energy independence and all of
that is where
locally
you know
cited
small scale
renewable resources
really comes into play
thank you representative samsic has a
question
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um could you comment
a little bit about how you see
net meter generators
contributions to stabilizing energy
prices for new hampshire residents
in particular like was mentioned
the spikes in natural gas supply and
prices
how how does net metering contribute in
in that
equation
so
diversifying our generation resources in
general including
scale and fuel type or generation type
will great you know diversifying our
generation resources would help make
this region less vulnerable to
spikes in one specific fuel type so the
iso new england wholesale market
currently is i would say over-reliant in
natural gas generation
a lot of those
generators to somewhat protect
themselves against some of those very
high volatility and pricing that we've
seen this winter are also dual fuel and
so this winter we've seen a lot of oil
generation
in the grid kick on because when they
when
heating when oil is actually cheaper
than natural gas they'll switch
which
contributes to both having a dirtier
grid and having these high prices
because that's also not cheap
everybody that heats with oil is pretty
familiar with that this winter as well
so having
uh you know not all of the classic
having not a lot of all of our eggs in
one basket makes us less vulnerable to
the price volatility of the fuel
if if all of your eggs are in the
natural gas basket and like this winter
we've seen very high spikes in natural
gas prices
um that's resulted in much higher
default service bids
especially in certain utilities as i
said you know unitil the default service
rate is in the high teens
which we haven't seen that in quite a
while
and even eversource is
10.63 i think
thank you very much okay thank you very
much see no further questions i would
like to thank
both of you for presenting here this
afternoon and i would like to close the
public hearing on house bill
1629 and ask representative pimentel to
read off the blue sheet numbers for that
bill please
i already have a card for you on this uh
yes
so
thank you for filling out a second one
okay there are four names on the blue
sheet and they were all opposed
and on the um
house remote testimony
there were two in support and 113
opposed
okay thank you very much
so now let's open the public hearing on
house bill 1248
relative to the replacement power for
net metering customer generators
and i will introduce the
prime sponsor of this legislation
representative white
to introduce the legislation thank you
chairman and thank you members of the
committee i'll try to keep this brief i
know we're running over
uh house bill 1248 is a bill that would
require that certain customer generators
provide replacement power when they
cannot meet their grid export
obligations
that might throw up red flags for some
people here after discussion with
friends of the department of energy and
bouncing ideas off of other people i
believe that this bill
should not be passed in its current form
uh it's likely premature at the current
time as well
the bill dispen depends on a statutory
obligation that simply does not exist
currently
i'm still exploring ways that this
obligation could be imposed should we
decide that we need it and would welcome
that discussion among this committee in
both timing of and best practices for
implementing such an obligation with
that said
i think it's important to explain my
reasoning for introducing this bill
in hopes that it can stir up some ideas
and discussion
the general idea behind this is to
reduce risk
we've talked a lot today about grid
stabilization we've talked about texas
both last year and this year
uh
rising prices inflation all these things
these are all concerns and having a
stable grid and stable power and stable
prices is important
as our grid continues to become more
decentralized which i encourage and adds
additional renewable energy sources
these sources will provide a larger and
larger percentage of our state's energy
needs
i personally think renewable adoption is
great i'd love to see it at 50 i think
currently it's at what eight percent of
our grid production is renewable give or
take depending on how you calculate it
um
but these sources are intermittent and
as such that introduces risk to our grid
so as their market share increases so do
the risks associated with depending on
these
the goal with this bill or a future bill
would be to ensure that large customer
generators whom the grid becomes
dependent on much like traditional
utilities provide some type of insurance
while i do not intend to discourage
renewable adoption i personally am
planning on adopting at least two solar
installs on my property over the next
two years
especially not in the short term excuse
me while i do not intend to discourage
renewable adoption especially not in the
short term i do believe that it's our
responsibility to continually assess
risk
for our constituents to ensure a stable
power grid
thank you for the time i would ask that
this bill be referred to interim study
and i'm happy to answer any questions
thank you representative white for
introducing this bill
to make sure i understand the concept
are you basically saying that
net metered generation is typically
renewable
comes from renewable sources either
solar hydro
possibly wind
and that because those sources are
intermittent you feel there needs to be
some
requirement
that
when they can't provide their output
they have to
from from the generation source
specified they have to provide it from
some other
source
if it's effectively yes
it's simple math look at it
at only eight percent the grid it's not
a big risk right these these can go on
and off all day long it's not a big deal
at 20
30 50 whatever that becomes 10 years
from now 20 years from now that's
something we need to be concerned about
because that's now 50 of our grid that
is intermittent
that this is just
simply looking the basics now there are
things we have organizations that
oversee this and try to stabilize this
we have systems in place to make sure
this is smooth but as we've seen
from texas
that's not always the case granted i
think our i think i've lived in texas i
grew up in texas and prior to living
here i lived there for three years i've
lived in different areas of texas that
have different
uh that are regulated in different ways
either through a co-op or through a
traditional utility or where i can just
go and pick my utility as well
um i think our
regulatory
system here is actually better than
texas's in many ways um i think it
provides for a more stable grid um that
might not people might disagree with me
but my experience tells me so um
so yes i think to answer your question
yes
okay great thank you
representative callie pitts has a
question
yes i do um
thank you for taking the question the
first question i have is why wouldn't
you want this
bill
to be
an expedient to legislate while you work
on
the particulars that you want to work on
[Music]
that's the first question so could you
answer that yeah absolutely uh one
because i don't think my ideas are the
only important ones in this room i think
there's a lot
a lot of brains here with a lot of
better ideas
um that could potentially see angles
that need to be tweaked just like just
like we're seeing with this previous
bill right this where we found a
loophole this has been around for five
years and we haven't plugged a loophole
in the
uh what mr bilo testified to right so
five six years now we have a loophole
and a mishmash right and we had a lot of
brains on that there's a lot of people
looking at that for many years so the
more the more eyes the more people
thinking the more people strategizing
and discussing i think we can eventually
come up with a good law that would be my
hope that could help
help in the future to ensure this
may i follow up follow-up
if you
what i
perceive this bill to be saying is that
if i have
two megawatts of generation
and for some reason my generation fails
that i must provide
another source of power another source
of generation it doesn't say equal to
but i would think you want it to be
somewhat equal too
and is that
is that what this bill says because
i
you know we we know i think that there's
a lot of
things that have been up and running for
a while and that will probably
fail eventually
so he were saying that one of the
downfalls of starting
a solar farm or whatever you're going to
start
is that
if that fails or it becomes obsolete for
some reason
that you as the generator must provide
an alternative source to that
is that what this bill says
in short yes
in long it's more complicated than that
um
we are becoming dependent on
non-utilities there are no obligations
there are no obligations for me and my
4.99 megawatt farm to stay plugged in
it doesn't exist if i'm participating in
this particular program so that's the
concern is as more and more as we become
more and more dependent on these
non-utilities
that's a risk in our electrical grid um
and so the idea is to smooth out that
risk
right now it's not it's not an issue
right now right because again it's only
seven eight percent of our grid it's not
it's not a huge it affects our prices
but it's not going to affect
not having power for a week right
usually
sorry
thank you didn't mean to interrupt you i
apologize representative thomas is
recognized for a question
thank you miss cheer uh thank you for
taking my question i i think the idea of
this bill is great i think if you
promise to to deliver something and
you're getting paid for it and you don't
deliver on your promise you should be
either penalized or provide a
reciprocal product that that you had uh
promised for but i
i was going to ask you um based on what
you were saying and you're
recommending itl are are you implying
that
rather than have this committee spend
some time trying to fix a
a bill that may not be fixable it would
be better to come back
at a later time when
people have done maybe a collaborative
people have done more research and
effort into a better worded bill
yeah
yeah i'm open to that that's that's the
discretion of this committee um excuse
me uh interim study would be my
recommendation just so that we could
spend time looking into this although
i'm not 100 certain on
the logistics of how interim study works
i guess i'll learn that with the
new interim study i'm on but
follow
follow-up uh
well you
you're recommending itl no i was
recommending interim study she she
introduced the idea of it oh i excuse me
i was
misinformed
thank you
sorry
representative plett is recognized for a
question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question partially because i'm
struggling to do with a clerk job and
messing it up from time to time
i didn't i can relate i i didn't hear
your answer why you want to pull this
why you don't think it's ready for prime
time uh it's not ready for prime time
because it depends on an obligation that
doesn't exist it this is this obligates
this says that if you're a customer
generator generating two megawatts
uh
if you're gonna unplug you have to
provide backup well there is no
obligation for you to provide two
megawatts
you you can unplug
so so it simply doesn't work if we pass
it as it is today it doesn't do anything
because that obligation doesn't exist
otherwise
okay thank you more questions uh
representative lewicky is recognized for
a question
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative um
might you be pointing at the need for us
to have more intermittent peak load
generating power that can be called on
reliably when it's needed
yes
love those kinds of answers
i wish that our questions could be that
succinct
representative mcgee you got a succinct
question thank you mr chairman
uh i believe i do but it does require a
little of a pre-precursor
um i i think the the concept of the bill
i understand where you're going with the
grid security and all that it's a big
topic
um
but i think some of the stuff is getting
mixed up a little bit because a lot of
the generators are being seen even by
the iso new england as load reducers
because they're not iso new england
assets which means they aren't part of
the risk that's being managed for
reliability of the grid by the iceland
new england in general um so there
is there's more of a conversation to
have around how to do this right i
understand what you're saying about
obligation
um
but i guess
my question is
uh it appears that your bill is trying
to get at who is required to manage the
risk
and
and what you're saying is the individual
who is looking to produce solar and
maybe use it locally or sell it locally
if they're a generator
should share in the risk of reliability
that the grid operators have and i think
that's
you know there's a bigger conversation
there i think that's open to debate and
i think it likely only applies to
certain customer generators of a certain
size and again that's open to debate and
at the discretion of this committee to
determine um may i fall
follow up yeah i think i think that
that's what the icelandic one does
though if if there's an asset that's
being leveraged uh in their giant board
that we went and visited a couple of
years ago you'd have to go see it at iso
new england uh
you know
there are categories of generators that
are
are legitimate assets uh that they
manage
they are in a different category than
the people that you're trying to pull
into that category
so i think we we probably would have to
have more conversation around
really what the objective is because
if these folks are not being looked at
as load reducers and they're being
looked at as people that have to
constantly produce or they're going to
be penalized then you are going to kill
the adoption and i think you said that
that was not your aim right yeah my aim
is not to kill the adoption but there is
going to become there will be a point in
time where we don't look at them as load
reducers we look at them as
effectively you power you to you energy
utilities because we are so dependent on
them which is fine i i i'm okay with
that growing and and that adoption
taking place but that that is something
that we need to be looking out for over
the next
several years decade who knows right we
don't know obviously our adoption's
slower here in this state um that i
expect that to change simply based on
market forces we have
compounding inflation
logistical supply chain
issues fuel
uh you know fuel doesn't last forever um
there's all kinds of different things
right so i fully expect just based on
market forces we will continue to adopt
more solar wind and renewable energies
um so this is
this will become an issue if it's not
this year or next year maybe it's next
decade i don't know
yeah but
we'll follow up yeah the last thing i'll
say is just we're not texas right we're
not deregulated so we actually have
regulators whose responsibility it is to
manage the reliability of the grid so i
think that's you know
we need to understand the full picture
before we start inserting ourselves
saying we have to solve this problem
because i'm not sure we can solve it
from here okay remember we're not here
to discuss or debate we're here to ask
questions
representative samsic
thank you mr chairman thank you mr white
for being here and i too agree with the
premise of your bill i think it's it's
only sensible to say if you promise
something you have to deliver it
god knows the state has made many
promises that it's never kept
and however
um
one thing i'm a little perplexed about a
a unit a generator of one megawatt peak
i think is maybe a couple thousand
panels it's a big place
uh if i were an investor
or a municipality and i built something
like that
uh i would definitely want to make sure
that i get my money's worth
so uh
i'm buying it or i have a market for it
and so someone who's buying it for me
has an agreement with me a contract
contractual agreement
so there's no way i can default on that
without some kind of penalty so i think
that's the way it is right now that
nobody would be foolish enough to create
something like this and then when they
can't deliver they say sorry i don't
have enough power for you today you have
a contractual legal obligation right now
otherwise nobody would invest or build
something like that is is that is that
correct
that this is what's happening now
as far as i know that's the normal
pattern
i'm not 100 certain but that sounds
correct yes okay i believe that's how it
operates
uh
i believe someone testified earlier that
there are
these large installs have a direct
buyer essentially yeah yeah thank you
okay any further questions seeing none i
will call on
our last testifier on this bill that
would be joseph kwasnik
of concord representing himself mr
chairman i'm going to defer testimony
okay
mr kwasnik
has deferred
his testimony so
i guess we're done on this bill and
i've just been handed another pink card
kelly buchanan of clean energy new
hampshire would like to testify
thank you i would remind everyone if you
want to testify you have to submit a
pink card otherwise
we're out we're out of here
i apologize for tempting you with the
option of release um but i appreciate
your patience and the opportunity to
give some brief remarks today
um i'm glad to hear that the sponsor of
house bill 1248 had some productive
discussions with the department of
energy and relevant stakeholders to
really understand the mechanics and the
difficulties with the bill is submitted
so i'm going to deviate from my written
testimony which i have for you today a
bit and say that perhaps there are other
ways in which
we can
address the intermittency of distributed
energy resources
and it's
you know it's important to consider the
importance of grid modernization and a
smart grid that becomes more flexible
adaptable and reactive to that
intermittency issue and so
perhaps in light of that there might be
an opportunity in the future for the
committee to examine that in more detail
with that i
i believe in terms of clean energy new
hampshire's position position
we would be
happy to hear that the vote goes to
interim city or um happy to consider
an itl motion as as acceptable um and of
course that's at the jurisdiction of the
committee but with that i'd be glad to
take any questions and keep it brief
today
okay thank you any questions for
ms buchanan
seeing none i'll call on the next
folks who want to testify and that would
be
the
the ladies from
the granite state hydro power
association the tag team of
miss kroll and ms minnow
thank you mr chairman and good afternoon
again for the record my name is heidi
kroll i work at gallagher callahan and
gartrell and i represent the granite
state hydropower association and with me
today is madeline minnow with essex
hydro which is a member of the granite
state hydropower association
um i think a lot of the concerns that we
had with this bill have already been
addressed and we're
pleased to hear that this sponsor has um
spoken with folks at the department of
energy and and otherwise to kind of
understand one of the points we were
going to make which is that
this concept of kind of export
obligation doesn't really exist
currently in the net metering and group
net metering
world and the only thing i think we at
least i was going to add to the
conversation and it kind of came up a
little bit is that
in the context of group net metering
there is a contractual arrangement
between the generator
and
under our current law the municipal host
and the members in the group and so
in the context of negotiating that
contract
which includes all kinds of terms and
conditions you know
the consumers could
require the generator to meet certain
minimum performance standards
they could
require that there be a guarantee to a
minimum amount of financial savings
to the group members under the contract
and so there is there is that at least
um i think under the the current
scheme um
of how group net metering is working so
i just wanted to mention that
i'll just add that we you know we
appreciate the sponsor's concern about
grid reliability but that is you know
squarely in the purview of iso new
england to manage uh really and i want
to be careful not to
lump all of the customer generators in
the solar bucket right there are we
represent small hydro and though if
we're run of river we can be considered
intermittent it's in a very different
way
then solar or wind is intermittent and
so if you have a variety of renewable
resources they can actually complement
each other very well and their
generation profiles are very different
we are intermittent on a seasonal basis
as opposed to a daily basis right now
we're generating 24 7 very very steadily
for example
and then we also wanted to reiterate
that
any generator under five megawatts in
new england
has no
generation obligation so we own uh hydro
projects one that is over five megawatts
and all the rest are under and those are
treated extremely differently by iso new
england the one that is over five
megawatts is
visible to ice in new england at all
times we have to be able 24 7 to take a
curtailment signal or to take a must
generate signal
all of the ones under five megabytes
which is regardless of what generation
type it is this would apply if you had a
four megawatt natural gas plant which
probably doesn't exist but it would it
would be treated the same way it's based
on how much you can generate not what
you generate with
so those are treated very differently so
any generator under five megawatts you
know truly has no
uh generation obligation regardless of
what market it's participating in so i
did want to make that clear as well
thank you
would it be possible for either of you
to procure
and provide to this committee
a copy of a group net metering contract
that we could look at to understand how
group net metering
contracts are structured and how it all
works i think they're all different and
if it is between two private businesses
that is uh you know they they typically
include a confidentiality clause
um i will say that there are um anything
that's with a municipality so if you
know for example your municipality has
entered into a group meeting agreement
that likely had to be published in
um
the city council or the the select board
agenda so certainly i'm sure that there
are some out there because there are
municipalities participating grouping
and metering but
i don't have one to provide you and as
heidi said
they are likely entirely different every
every agreement you know every member
that i've potential member that i've
talked to
wants different terms and conditions
either
as far as exactly like performance
guarantee or duration of the contract or
different conditions under which they
could leave or join or
things like that so i think they're all
quite different
yeah i was looking for a sample not a uh
just a representative sample contract
not
a contract that that would cover all
possibilities yeah but thank you for
that uh representative pled had a
question
let's see if i can remember
the uh
your statement of iso new england uh
over five megawatts and under five
megawatts they don't look accurate of
course
as time goes on and the under five
megawatts get bigger and bigger as a
slice of the pie could that change and i
realize there's
federal versus state jurisdictions but
if we want to keep a system together
maybe have some cooperation between the
ice and new england and the states to
procure information
to essentially dispatch were they not
now dispatching uh yeah absolutely of
course rules are not written in stone
and they could iso new england could
change their requirements
utilities can change their
interconnection requirements um fairly
willingly actually we're undergoing some
of that in maine where maine has seen a
big
boom in distributed generation and as a
result even though we've been existing
generators for a long time central maine
power is revising their interconnection
agreements which affects some of the
existing resources which
their goal is to have more visibility
into some of the smaller resources so
yes of course
that's why i said the reliability is iso
new england's
primary responsibility and so i have
faith that they will do what is
necessary to ensure that we continue to
have a reliable grid and if that means
that we start to have more and more
smaller resources they may want more
visibility into some of those smaller
resources and they have the ability to
require that
representative callie pitts has a
question
my question would be that there's no con
if if i understand you're right there's
no contractual obligation for the
smaller producers
and as i sit here
i
wonder
if
we are ignoring
one
branch of the government
call the courts
and whether we can or you can
do you believe that you could in your
contract compel a private business
to do something that they are not
capable of doing
uh
i'm not an attorney i i'm not going to
even i ask the questions so i'm not sure
but obviously if they're not capable of
doing it they're not capable of doing it
there could be in a contract a clause
where there's a financial penalty for
non-performance
that's typically how that shows up right
if you can't generate
if you're uh you know it's happened that
major generators
connection to the grid goes down right
in a big storm they can't generate even
though they should be generating and
that causes some very big problems
they can't generate if they're not
connected to the grid or they at least
can't put the power out there
they can't do what they can't do but
there can be financial penalties for
failing to meet an obligation
typically that's how that and can i
follow follow-up can that and that could
be
a contractual one of one of your
stipulations in your contract that if
you cannot perform or you choose not to
perform
that
for the duration of whatever your
contract is there could be financial
consequences yes such as
heidi was mentioning in for group hosts
and group members they negotiate the
terms of their agreement and so you
could say that i'm your group member
even if you're not generating and not
getting paid
i expect a certain amount of
credit being shared with me
so the the host may not be making any
revenue
but they've guaranteed that they're
going to make a minimum amount of
payment to their members so if their
equipment breaks down and they can't
generate for a whole year but in under
their contract terms they've said we
will share a certain minimum amount of
value with you they're still going to
make those payments otherwise they'll be
in breach of their contract thank you
okay before i call on the next
questioner i just want to point out we
have one more person who has signed up
to testify on this bill and i'm going to
close this public hearing at
2 55
so that we can take a five-minute break
before the next public hearing starts
so i just want to alert everybody to
that reality
representative samsic has a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question this question goes to
miss minnow uh because of the idea that
the contractual issues
uh i think you your your hydro uh
businesses probably have this all the
time but i'm assuming that you have
similar contractual legal obligations to
some of your customers to say we will
provide you with so much power
and so
in your particular case or in that
business case uh what are the clauses
that that would
preclude let's say if all of a sudden
something happened and you couldn't
deliver
what is the what is the normal remedy
for that
um you know i can't speak to the details
of all of our contracts we do um
market our energy in different ways you
know they're not some of them are group
net metering hosts but some of them um
have direct contracts with different
purchasers
i'll say that some
some purchasers go out specifically
for
guaranteed firm service in specific
tranches
so there will be a peak a guaranteed
peak delivery a guaranteed delivery and
we generally do shy away from that a
little bit because the penalties can be
extremely severe for non-performance
so
yeah usually you're either going to have
to pay them
to be able to buy replacement power or
buy the replacement power yourself to
transfer to them
thank you much as we all enjoy a good
brainstorming session i think we're
going to cut this one short and
thank you both for testifying and call
on griffin roberge from the department
of energy for
some final comments on house bill 1248
thank you chairman vos members of the
committee griffin roberge new hampshire
department of energy
i'm going to keep it as brief as
possible
and no surprise doe is neutral
i did just want to say that i did reach
out to representative white
i think it was last week maybe two weeks
ago
just to briefly discuss the bill he and
i had a good conversation on it and
everything like that and certainly
willing to
be part of any type of process to
further talk about this language but
more or less what i wanted to say today
has largely been expressed by people who
testified earlier you know in short new
hampshire doesn't have any type of
statutory requirement for custer
customer generators to fulfill any
export obligations so
the bill is requiring replacement power
for an export obligation that doesn't
exist
again certainly willing to uh work with
representative white and other
stakeholders on on this issue but
like i said most of my comments would
have been addressed already
great any questions for mr roberge
seeing none
i'm going to call the
public hearing on house bill 1248
closed and asked representative pimentel
to read us the blue sheet results
mr chairman there are three names on the
blue sheet all opposed
and on the remote testifying
uh one support and 115 oppose
thank you very much
so we will be
taking a
a break until three o'clock at which
time we will come back to hear our final
bill our final house bill
for this session year that's hb 1491 fn
local relative to natural gas
transmission pipeline safety we'll see
you at three o'clock
okay
time for our final public hearing
on a house bill for the 2022 session
year
and that is house bill
dash fn-local
don't ask me why it's not a
early bill but it's not i have no idea
why
it's relative to natural gas
transmission pipeline safety
and i'm going to call first on the prime
sponsor of this bill representative joe
alexander to introduce this legislation
take it away joe
uh thank you um chairman vos and members
of uh science technology and energy i
know you saved the best bill for last so
i appreciate that
hp 1491 is
for the record my name is joe alexander
i represent the town of goffstown which
is hillsboro district six
hp 1491 is advanced notification
legislation so it seeks to create
pipeline safety dialogue between
property developers and owners and
natural gas transmission pipeline
operators
when new land use or property
development is planned near a
transmission pipeline
so why it's needed um in tennessee
developers built homes right up right up
to a right-of-way which resulted in land
owners assuming the right-of-way was
their backyard
so they were building structures in
unsafe manners
in pennsylvania developer designed homes
as close to 16 feet from a pipeline
which would then not allow them to make
any more modifications to the existing
development
so
with the early notification provided in
this bill we can prevent the necessary
modifications
that would take significant time and
costs
to developers later in the application
or the building process so
this bill would
basically make sure that the the
notification is in advanced developers
know where the pipeline is
through mapping data and then they can
kind of modify their development based
on that information provided
so that would be within that would
require
developers to notify the the pipeline
existing pipeline in the state within a
thousand feet of a proposed development
so
this is good because by knowing where
the pipeline is and how it's constructed
developers will be able to modify their
designs on new developments with the
location of the pipeline in mind
and that's why you know i solicited
advice from different groups and this
this legislation is supported by new
hampshire home builders association as
kind of a preemptive
way to make sure that we're developing
in a safe
way
so
it's forward thinking so currently
there's really only there's only one
interstate pipeline it's in northern new
hampshire
it goes through burlington through
berlin gorham and into maine it's about
80 miles long so right now this bill
would only affect that pipeline um but
if in the future there are pipelines
being constructed it would address
those as well
so i i believe strongly that workforce
housing development is very important
issue facing new hampshire and it and i
believe that this bill is going to be
preemptive to help handle
some of these issues
and make sure that development that the
conversation is had before the shovel
breaks the ground on development and
i have an amendment available i've
solicited advice from the new hampshire
municipal association who was originally
opposed to this bill um but the
amendment addresses their concerns and
nature's behind me able to address that
as well i'd be happy to hand that to the
committee as well so in conclusion the
amendment um
the
this bill you know has broad support
it's a preemptive measure and allows for
advanced notification so i asked the
committee um
for your support on this bill thank you
well thank you very much for bringing
this important bill to us
looks like an excellent bill i have one
quick question
the bill specifies that
for a new residential or non-residential
development that is located in whole or
park within 1 000 feet of the center
point of a natural gas transmission
pipeline
where did the number 1000 come from was
that arbitrary arbitrarily chosen or is
there a is there some
uh
safety guidelines or science behind that
number um thank you for the question
chairman um
i was under the impression and i have um
bj perry is here to help address it he's
um lobbying for the only pipeline in new
hampshire but um from the experiences of
the pipeline companies most of the
issues that come from the pipeline
really affect the the first thousand
feet and after that um the safety
the safety is affected within the first
thousand feet and then after that um
they can address it a little easier so
that's where all the problems arise
so the thousand feet comes from past
experience with dealing with with these
issues yes sir
great thank you further questions uh
representative mcgee has a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
alexander representative alexander for
taking my question
so the purpose of the bill is to
institute requirements around notice
is that is that correct yep
um so the the
the permit shall not be issued unless
one of these three requirements are met
so the developer has received written
consent from a natural gas pipeline
operator number one or number two the
developer has not received the consent
but is filed with local land use board
written correspondence from the pipeline
operator demonstrating discussions have
occurred or number three the developers
filed dated and written correspondence
with local land use boards that
demonstrates attempts to contract the
nitrogen pipeline operator so
there's no way the pipeline company
would be able to hinder the development
um as long as the developer has
documented advanced notification for the
pipeline being constructed okay thank
you and follow-up follow-up uh and in
follow-up you mentioned that there's an
amendment that was that maybe patch
would be speaking to after you
or natch i'm sorry i always remember
that it's pronounced like patch
nate it is okay nate um
you mentioned that amendment so you're
not going to present it and he's going
to present it or you want to tell us
what what it is the change that you're
proposing yep so um i'm not a member of
the committee so i'll be happy to hand
it to you and hopefully somebody on the
committee would be able to pick this up
oh thank you
so i'm just going to keep one copy for
myself
um so the amendment would do two things
the amendment would shift the
responsibility for the notification of
an application within a thousand feet of
the pipeline from the local land use
board to the developer so it would make
the developer notify not the local land
use board and that was a significant um
concern with nhma and i believe that
helps address the fiscal note because if
you look at the
um
the methodology it basically says that
there may be an indeterminable impact on
local expenditures and it doesn't say
whether the form of notices
to pipeline operators are required so if
you look at the methodology i i believe
the amendment fixes a lot of the
fiscal impact of this bill and i i
believe it'd be
negligible if any impact on it so that
shift of responsibility and then number
two the local land use boards shall make
available the national national pipeline
mapping system geospatial data which is
already public information available for
people
thank you you're welcome
okay thank you further questions for
uh representative alexander
representative pementel
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative alexander for taking my
question
um
is a great bill um i'm just curious
about
um
what are the are there any current
restrictions about
i mean obviously this is about
notification but restrictions on how
close a development can actually be to
the pipeline
um i don't know the exact foot and i
don't want to speak necessarily to
buffer zone of of that i believe it's
less than 100 feet though
so but i have i have somebody here that
can answer that for you
thank you you're welcome
additional questions for representative
alexander j.d bernardi is recognized
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
alexander uh how does this bill
interface uh with the requirements from
dig safe
um i believe this bill would comp
complement the requirements and dig safe
so no no problems of
um no if that's i'm i'm pretty sure
digsafe is a national
program so it says in here
um that a natural gas transmission
pipeline means an interstate pipeline as
that term is divided in u.s code section
330115 so it says
um it complements digsafe it doesn't go
against xavier anyway thank you you're
welcome
okay additional questions for
representative alexander
seeing none
i thank you representative for
introducing this legislation thank you
members committee looks like very solid
legislation
i would like to call on our next
presenter who is b.j perry of bedford
new hampshire he represents
tc energy and give us will give us
the
industry's view of this situation mr
perry thank you very much thank you
committee appreciate the opportunity uh
thank you for uh reference referencing
dig safe appreciate that it's always a
great program so it makes me happy when
i hear people mention dig safe thank you
as chairman votes mentioned my name is
bj perry of bedford new hampshire and
i'm with tc energy's state government
and community relations team i thank you
for providing tc energy with the
opportunity to offer testimony in
support of eight of hb 1491 the pipeline
safety bill as this is my first coming
before the committee i ask you please be
gentle
for over 70 years tc energy formerly
known as transcanada has been providing
energy including natural gas to
consumers across the continent in fact
tc energy operates in 40 states here in
the country and supplies more than 25
percent of the natural gas demand in
north america
in new hampshire our interstate pipeline
spans 80 miles across coast county
connecting vermont and maine known as
our portland natural gas transmission
system this line transports nearly four
hundred thousand decatharms and has
helped provide new opportunities to
providing energy and economic
development
as some members of this committee might
know our recent
hot tap tie-in project last summer up in
colebrook helped supply the necessary
energy infrastructure for the rubber
glove manufacturing company that was
awarded a multi-million dollar defense
contract and will help create up to 300
new jobs in the north country
on a personal note as a lifelong
resident of new hampshire it was a great
honor to be part of this accomplishment
for our state and that's what tc energy
is all about providing solutions and
being part of some amazing programs that
are making a difference
to that point some of our other projects
across north america include our evc
technology that converts methane to
water vapor and co2 thus reducing ghg
our saddlebrook double-sided solar panel
project which can generate
enough electricity to power 30 000 homes
and tc energy's three mile canyon farm
project over in oregon where the
extraction of methane gas from the for
the manure of 33 000 dairy cows is
occurring and rng is traveling to
california via our interconnect pipeline
system resulting in energy being
provided to an energy-hungry state along
with the avoidance of a hundred and
thirty six thousand tons of co2 a year
which translates to an annual ghg
reduction of nearly 28 29 000 vehicles
coming off the road
along our commitment to new and
sustainable energy is our commitment to
safety and that is why i'm here today
our pipeline safety programs are among
the most robust in the industry and the
most important part of our business one
of the best demonstrations of our
commitment to safety is our long
standing and ongoing pipeline integrity
program this annual process maintains
the integrity safety and reliable
operations of our pipeline systems
on top of this program every mile of
pipeline pump compressor facility or
generation station is made using proven
technology and integrated industry
leading safety systems once constructed
all pipelines and facilities are
monitored constantly whether that's from
inside the pipe on the ground or from
the air
we've invested more than a billion
dollars in these programs and believe
more can be done and that's why we're
supporting and advocating for pipeline
safety bills such as 1491.
tc energy supports this important bill
and believes its provisions increase
public and operator safety while
preventing the potential for damage to
interstate natural gas transmission
pipelines the communication framework
established in this bill affords
interstate pipeline operators the
advanced data necessary to continue
supporting the safe and reliable
transportation of natural gas hb 1491
promotes a heightened commitment to
public and operator safety by requiring
developers to provide gas transmission
line operators with the advanced
information needed to better adhere to
the pipeline and hazardous materials
safety administration guidelines
third-party damage generally caused
during construction and excavation
activities remain a leading cause of
pipeline as incidents the communication
framework established in 1491 greatly
reduces the risk of third-party damage
to pipeline infrastructure by requiring
affected stakeholders the affected the
interstate pipeline company that's me
and and the developer to collaborate and
exchange information at an earliest
possible opportunity
i hope
my comments today answered in some of
your questions you might have and you
learned a little bit more why we support
uh 1491. i know you guys have all worked
really hard today
and we're the last thing up on the
agenda so i'm happy to answer questions
now or later to about our commitment to
safety and other tc energy programs you
might want to learn about to ensure we
have the necessary information you need
when
making sure we're doing everything we
can for pipeline safety i thank the
interested parties for speaking in favor
of this bill and i appreciate your time
not only to learn about pipeline safety
but for all the hard work you do for the
people of new hampshire we can all agree
that we're a special state and we are
committed to safety community and all
working together hb 1491 just does that
in true new hampshire fashion
thank you thank you mr perry excellent
uh representative platt has a question
yes thank you mr chair thank you for
addressing my question mr perry you want
a mile a minute you were reading do you
have uh that testimony
yeah i'll be submitting it as well and
emailing you guys as well thank you i'll
look it up with my cell phone number
that's the best way to call me as well
that's fine just as long as i have it so
i can supplement right here
um this bill is only a notification bill
in no way it tries to uh increase what
you could uh you paid for right of way
uh uh and so you paid for that you're
not trying to expand it it's just
notification now it's notification is
because we're getting closer to the
right of way let's have the discussion
early let's have that the dialogue so
we're ensuring that we're doing
everything we can to you know working
together for pipeline safety as well as
working together for development
especially in these rural areas in new
hampshire
thank you uh
representative alexander and his
testimony alluded to the fact that in
tennessee
some developers were
apparently
building houses as close as 16 feet from
a natural gas pipeline could you explain
to us
what uh some of the
uh
safety hazards are in doing something
like that i'll let you use your
imagination uh but no that's in the
state of pennsylvania uh in tennessee
they were building in the backyards but
i mean when you're encroaching right on
that is some
very very controversial things i mean
because once again i'm talking about
encroaching up to a thousand feet at the
crosstalk right away i mean so if you're
going to
dig a new pool if you're going to do
something i mean you can you can ding
the line and that's the last thing we
want to do i mean because it's integrity
and so forth now of course we pride
ourselves on having one of the top
safety commitments and you know of any
energy company so we're johnny on the
spot and we're going to be right there
to ensure that we're our asset and
retainability team is right there to do
everything we can and work with to
ensure safety and getting that line back
up and running
so
are there no setback requirements from
pipeline right of ways
you would have to talk to local
authorities across the country and and
so forth i mean so if we can have more
dialogue and have more conversations to
prevent this then let's do it that's why
1491 is so important because it gets us
right to the it gets right to the crux
of the issue let's have a conversation
let's get it done and let's ensure we
have safety and we're having a great
communication to put good new
development in the state of new
hampshire
okay great thank you representative
thomas has a question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question so explain to me um how much
further this bill takes
um
us
more than what we currently have for the
safe program so dig safe you know so
it's you know
i hate one i really want to say the
commercial in my head uh
i'm not like i said i'm happy you
mentioned it makes me happy by the way
you guys are saying dig safe it makes me
so happy to hear that because it's a
great program uh great education program
it helps us um
there's it goes anywhere from based on
local area it could be 25 to 150 feet
from a right-of-way
but once again as we ta as
representative alexander alluded to and
this people are putting you know not
realizing where that line really is
where is that easement where's that
right-of-way and they're assuming that's
their backyard so let's try to prevent
that so that just adds a little bit more
you know obviously it's a thousand feet
because we'd like to have a little more
safety and have a little more
conversation
but that's what we need to do
follow up
thank you so i know that in my town of
londonderry there is i believe it's the
concord lateral that runs through our
backyard
a few hundred feet off the back of our
high school i believe
but that area is in some parts is
marked by these
orange and white poles yes separated by
us
some distance
is that the right of way or can they get
or is there some distance beyond those
polls that people are not supposed to
build anything beyond those polls and
just every and just a reminder i would
be uh very clear on this and you guys
are great
this is for interstate pipelines this
legislation is affecting interstate
pipelines so we're connecting so when
we're at you know up and up in carlos
county
i see yeah so it's not so it's not other
pipeline companies you know it's
interstate pipelines and
going through the state of new hampshire
thank you
representative callie pitts has a
question
when
someone
builds a home
or a business or whatever
they have to go through the local i
believe the local planning boards or
whatever controls building licensing
permitting in their
town or state
in kolas county where you run through
have you given
your maps of the
pipeline to the appropriate
town officials
and to the county planning board
that would be so i don't want to give
you the wrong answer uh because that
would be our land representatives who
handle all of that for our company um it
is readily accessible online we share
those kmz's on a regular basis with
anybody you know they can understand and
all those pipeline infrastructures are
public record
but not but i'm happy to ensure to have
my land representative reach out to you
to walk you through our
our process so you can understand that
because the last thing i want to do is
give you the wrong information
you're right
way back we had a house bill
that had a pipeline safety committee and
one of the concerns that we had was that
some
town officials especially new town
officials or people who haven't lived in
a town for a long time
would
maybe not aware
of what was under their feet
and that's why i
i would like that information
if these planning boards
and
proper land use authorities
have been notified and and i think
that's really important no i think
you're absolutely right and we like i
said we uh we constantly our land
representatives are constantly talking
to local town officials uh on a regular
basis uh such as as i referenced the uh
the call the colebrook hot tap expansion
the permit cost 16 and 18 cents uh and
that you know it's you know and they
were it was great and um it gave us the
opportunity to
share that information and as i
mentioned we talked to land
representatives
community relations we are talking to
local people on a regular basis the
first thing you guys saw that i did when
i got to this committee i handed out an
asset map of tc energy new hampshire so
you guys saw that little blue line going
across coast county uh you know giving
you some key facts including the 4.6
million dollars in property taxes that
we pay um but you know it's the first
thing i did you know because you know
traditionally it was if this was a tc
energy meeting we'd start it with a
safety moment uh you know veric because
safety is the number one most important
thing to us so if my bosses are watching
i'm probably going to get in trouble for
not starting with a safety moment
okay representative mirner is recognized
for a question yes i happen to be the
county planner for the unincorporated
towns and everything up there and i can
tell you we have detailed maps because
the 4.6 million dollars you talk about
that's a
that's a big thing on the tax tax base
utility tax bill we had that bill years
ago because that was one of the biggest
screaming from all my towns up there
when we were
kicking around 700 a few years ago
because that was a big source of income
for the towns up there
so uh it is watched and wanted very
closely by the towns
did you have a question you wanted to
ask no i just wanted somebody had asked
i was just answering callie jackie this
question thank you
uh representative samsich has a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
perry thank you
um
so you we were discussing previously
this issue of
why a thousand feet and we heard
the thousand feet is
kind of the largest area where there
could be
issues that
may be damaging to the surrounding area
could you kind of elaborate a little bit
of what the typical
problems could be in that thousand area
distance it could be the same thing as
we mentioned just you know why 8-1-1 is
just as important it's you know it's
basically you know it's it's 8-1-1 on
steroids if you will to put it in a
better better way and it's ensuring that
you know within that thousand feet i
mean because think about how many how
mean how many feet are we using in this
building today you know would be would
be you know if we were up in coast
county would be close to encroaching on
the pipeline you know and that's not
just the building it could be the
parking lot it could be other things
that are that are being addressed to the
foundation etc so we want to ensure that
we are giving plenty of room and the
thing is and it could be
remember it's a notification of up to a
thousand feet we're not telling you to
not do it from a thousand feet we're
having conversations that if you're a
thousand feet away let's review the plan
collectively as a group and say oh no
your parking lot going over here your
driveway okay that's good you know it's
like we just want to give one more sense
of safety excuse me mr perry my that was
not my question my question was can you
give us some examples
of when there have been problems
associated with natural gas pipelines
where where people were saying a
thousand feet that's kind of a good
distance where we can be sure that
whatever happens people will be safe
sure can you give us some some examples
of what could happen not to say i'm not
implying that it does all the time i'm
just saying
some area some examples of why a
thousand feet would be useful some of it
is is regulatory reformed you know with
with fisma um and you know as i
mentioned the pipeline hazardous
material safety administration under uh
d.o.t uh so some of that is based on
their numbers and then um
as we alluded it's
just ensuring more dialogue more
conversation and just making sure i
don't want to give you examples and put
things into your head that you know
could or could not happen um that's not
what i'm
i don't want to do that to be honest
with you you know or lead you down a
road that you're thinking something else
i'm here to encourage advanced
notification legislation to prevent
safety and i'd like i said on the
regulatory side i'm happy to put you in
conversations with our regulatory people
to help you better understand well i
still haven't heard an answer to the
question of what incidents may have
happened
uh representative substitute did give
you any no he didn't answer yes he did
he said he's not going to give you
examples
of what could or could not happen so
let's move on let me ask a follow-up
question different from what this all
right make sure it's different
i just wanted to inquire whether your
company has in any way been considering
uh the idea of transporting
not just methane but hydrogen in your
pipelines or a mixture of the two i know
some utilities are doing that already
there's a lot of conversations utility
companies and energy companies that are
having that absolutely absolutely i mean
tc energy prides itself on looking at
all forms of energy it's who we are it's
what we do i mean we
as i mentioned we we are not afraid to
explore all forms of energy double-sided
solar panels uh hydrogen uh
renewable natural gas hydro we'll have
those conversations because
you know when we're paying 163 more in
energy costs up in this area let's have
a conversation about energy okay thank
you good good response representative
partial is recognized for a question
thank you chair and my
applause to uh both yourself and the
sponsor of the bill it's very well
drafted uh i do have a question and that
is um
looking it over
understanding this is for interstate uh
that they made that clear but is this
for development for new
developments or if i have an existing
um
to cite your example if i want to put a
pool in my backyard
um
and i have an old parent right away in
my backyard i'm still within a thousand
foot of your pipeline
um
does that will this apply to my
uh pool and will it be up to my
local permit granting agent my my um
my municipal office have been granting a
building permit
in order to make me aware of this
situation well your building permit is
go is it will be handled through your
building through your local authority uh
the conversation uh is for new
developments uh in the area and i just
use the pools to try to give a general
example uh new developments going up in
new construction uh along in interstate
along an interstate pipeline
okay so it doesn't apply to existing
constructions
thank you so much thank you thank you
representative plett is recognized for a
question thank you mr chair mr perry has
this legislation in similar form if not
the same form been introduced and or
passed in other states yes sir uh the
state of tennessee uh it is currently
being voted on in the in the ohio
legislature it's being introduced in in
kentucky as well
so i thought in good safety and good
collaborative efforts here in this in
the 603 that i would uh bring it to new
hampshire
great idea representative bernardi has a
question
thank you mr chairman uh mr perry what
type of markers exist on top of
this
interstate pipeline to to give someone a
visual that hey i may be a thousand feet
and i better ask somebody
uh currently uh the the markers that are
indicated are
along the root of our pipeline
so this is where you would work with uh
because i mean it could be a thousand
feet could be going through
you know existing field of some sort but
having the conversation and getting the
kmz file will determine exactly from the
existence of the pipeline where those
yellow markers are that we've indicated
and seen and you're welcome to come up
to coast county and uh represent and i
will give you a nice little tour of it
come come come come see come and see it
um you know we'll go to the golf course
too um
you'll see you'll see the yellow markers
and then from there it's a thousand feet
from that pipeline
thank you
representative mcgee has a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
perry for taking my question
uh so
based on the language in here it says to
the center line of the pipeline a
thousand feet so that would be two
thousand feet right one thousand on each
side right so it's actually two thousand
feet times eighty miles
so it's it's quite a bit of land that
you're talking about here so
uh are you aware of any current projects
in coast county that would be impacted
by the implementation of this law
because i'm not curious not to my
understanding of course when we had the
conversation with
renko the rubber glove manufacturing
company we had
dialogue from the get-go uh to ensure
that everything was
you know integrity safety and everything
was ready to go and that we could have
the demand ready to go for them so we
could help create 300 new jobs and you
know for their 95 000 square foot
edition that they put on yeah there was
95 000 that was the facility 90 or 95.
just to follow on follow up yeah so so
you it you've had this interstate
pipeline for a while so i'm sure you
know who your neighbors are i guess the
better question would be
are you aware of any um
businesses or land owners along the
pipeline route that would be affected by
this
uh
you know i would say if they sell that
property you know and then they somebody
wants to put a development and that's
the whole point of the legislation is
that we can take those preventative
measures and have those advanced
conversations so if i sold i owned
parcels of land up in say gorham for
example and i decided to sell them to
you know a you know abc development
company and they want to put something
the advanced notification legislation
will would kick into effect to make sure
that you know tc energy hi and uh and
abc building development will have a
conversation so we can ensure safety and
integrity and land conservation and
preservation in the state of new
hampshire
okay
so
could you explain on page two
starting at line three section five
it says upon receiving notice of a
planned development in accordance with
this section a pipeline operator shall
locate and mark the natural gas pipeline
facilities
and provide pipeline facility
information to the developer
by other means such as marking up design
drawings and providing maps does that
mean
both physically
on the ground as well as on design
drawings is that the purpose of that
absolutely
absolutely let's just have let's cover
one more line to ensure one more value
to safety you know just you know just
like when digsafe comes in and they're
putting the lines on the ground
absolutely it's just giving us
one more time here's your drawing here
it is yeah you just saw it in person
great thank you representative callie
pitts has another question i have a
question on jurisdiction
who controls
these things on an interstate pipeline
pipelines have been in the news lately
are there different control factors
for interstate
versus entrusting yeah i mean it's all
classifications and so forth and how
we're regulated and we're regulated by
ferc that's what i thought so
may
my follow-up would be is
can we
legitimately
put these regulations into effect
because they can be super see
can they be superseded
by ferc
so the conversation is about advanced
notification legislation for act for
them to obtain a permit
a state permit a local municipal permit
that is that is issued by them so it's
the town i mean as you as you indicated
and members indicated earlier it's the
communities that issue the building
permits
so we're having the dialogue here to add
one more bite of safety so we can so
they can get that permit
the local building permit
so the answer is no ferc wouldn't uh
have any effect we pass it in tennessee
it's in ohio and we're and we're and
we're moving for and we're moving
forward in new hampshire and hopefully
kentucky
representative lewicki has a question
thank you mr chairman um my question is
really not germane to this i'll take it
offline
okay thank you for recognizing that
any additional ques representative
thomas has a question thank you chair
uh i'll assume i'm filling in for
representative lucky's question
uh since i already asked two of them
um
it certainly came to my mind does this
legislation
would this pre uh legislation
effectively put
uh
i guess tc energy in a position where
they could
effectively deny a permit no
no it's it's creating conversation to
ensure conversation where you know we're
not the local planning authority it's it
is the attempt of the of the person who
wants to do development to have
conversation and dialogue with us to
ensure they know where the pipeline is
for pipeline safety
so
follow-up
so uh not to
reiterate but then again so
uh the local planning board could still
uh overrule your objection
um
on that and and if they did is is there
any recourse we're not objecting
remember our role in this is to have a
dialogue of conversation relative to
where they're building in the pipeline
and provide feedback and information
as it relates to regulations as it
relates to fisma classifications so they
know when they're building where it's
going to be you know the uh the the the
yay or nays our and our role is
supplying them as indicated in this bill
the mapping ability
the plotting and where it is and where's
a thousand feet from it
so that but it goes back to the
authority of the local planning board
and obtaining their permit
we're just having we're having the
dialogue of conversation for you know
for safety and integrity thank you
okay we uh
we've got two more people who who want
to testify here so
uh make it quick uh representative mcgee
i will do so thank you for indulging me
mr chair um
when i'm looking at uh the place that
says the
the jurisdiction of the local land use
board this is on page two uh
section six and i'm looking
at number a
it says um the board uh
she'll basically
have jurisdiction
to
allow a building permit
if the developer has received written
consent from the natural gas pipeline
operator that
has filed this consent with such
regional planning commission and then it
goes on to say or these other things
right so you can have reached out sure
and not have heard back yet and you know
so you're trying to cover all
contingencies but it does
give the pipeline company the ability to
respond and say no right yeah we give
our advice and say no but you know but
that but that is not our authority our
our intent here is to ensure that we are
working with the the developer of this
piece of property to ensure they know
where the interstate pipeline is so we
can ensure safety and integrity that's
the crux of the bill we're not you know
we're we're not going to prevent
economic development from happening from
more housing coming into play we don't
want that that's why we played a key
role in the colebrook hot tap project to
allow 300 new jobs
we could eliminate that if we wanted to
then that you know this is your bill um
you know i i'm here to talk you know why
we're advocating for this bill on a
safety and integrity matter okay thank
you so now thank you i appreciate it
that's a great question
so representative mcgee are you
advocating that we change the word
shall
on line seven to may
a building permit shall not be issued
should we change that to may not be
issued unless the following one of the
following three conditions is met yeah i
don't know if that helps it
i don't know if that solves for what i'm
talking about yeah
what are you saying jackie
all right well we can discuss this later
i i just wanted to understand what your
question was uh the point i'm making is
that there's an explicit item here that
says that we would be granting the that
the developer has received written
consent from the natural gas pipeline
operator and has filed this consent with
the regional planning board so if that
consent isn't given then that would
prevent development right
unless one of the other two right
conditions is met but you're right yes
which is why i suggested that
we may want to make it advisory rather
than uh
make it
mandatory yeah we should consider that
anyway okay
we got to move on here so i'm going to
thank
mr perry for his
his excellent testimony and
excellent
answers to his questions
and called nate grays from the new new
hampshire municipal association to
testify on
this legislation mr grays
thank you mr chair nate graves for the
new hampshire municipal association
we do support this bill as amended
as uh
representative alexander already
described the amendment would just
change
slightly how this operates which would
save some municipal costs
i guess the best way
to think about this bill or the way i
think about it at least is it
essentially makes the pipeline operator
in a butter if the pipeline is within a
thousand feet of the property to be
developed
and so
essentially what that would do was
require notification just like any other
butter and so the pipeline operator
should come in and describe whether
there's a problem so for example if
someone was going to take a pool on top
of where the pipeline is running through
that's going to be a problem if
someone's going to do blasting within a
thousand feet that's probably going to
be a problem
but if they're just going to pave a
parking lot that may not be a problem
but in either case or whatever the case
may be it gives the pipeline operator
the opportunity to inform the planning
board
and so we don't have any accidents and
so that's what
my thought about how this bill operates
is and i'm happy to answer any questions
that's an excellent description of
the bill in
its essence are there any further
questions for mr grace
representative oxenom
i have a question about the the thousand
feet and and the issue of a butters if
if property lines they're not always
nice neat rectangles
and someone could own
you know 40 feet at the at the back end
and they're separated by someone else
who is the a butter so you're not the
abutter but you're within a thousand
feet are they going to be informed
is there going to be a way for them to
be informed if they're buying the
property and they're thinking they're
going to do something with those 40
so it would it would be
the way this would work is if they
propose a development so if they're just
buying the property unless the owner
tells them or they look out and see the
yellow stakes or whatever
no but presumably they they know where
their property is presumably they've
walked around before buying it
um
but my assumption would be that you know
if it's their property and then another
property in the pipeline and they want
to dig a pool or whatever
when they notify the pipeline the
pipeline's going to look at the same
maps everybody else's and say that's not
an issue and let them know it's not
going to be an issue because clearly
they're they're building they're
building on their property not next to
the pipeline so that's my assumption of
how it would work
and you wouldn't hear an objection from
the pipeline at the planning board
session
representative mcgee thank you mr
chairman and thank you
mr grace for taking my question
i just wanted to ask whether you could
speak to the amendment that i had asked
prior speakers to speak to just tell me
what it in essence what you're trying to
do with this so it makes two changes um
one it places the burden of notification
on the applicant rather than the land
use board that's consistent with
the statutes related to abutters
although it is often the case that land
use boards will
make the list of a butters in
conjunction with the applicant and
provide that notice upon payment of the
fee
presumably that's going to happen here
the other change
um which is to section four
is it just changes uh
the effect of the bill as a whole
the bill as a whole
to those municipalities that actually
have a pipeline or which may have a
pipeline in the future because it
doesn't make a lot of sense for
a municipality without an interstate
pipeline to have to
look at these maps and you know actually
do work on this
but it does make sense if you actually
have a pipeline or if in the future a
pipeline goes through
um just follow up follow up so
the the notice on the applicant how
would that work
so
the applicant would have to notify the
um the pipeline operator
who has presumably provided information
to the municipality um and worked with
the municipality to
um to to have this information available
i'm just wondering how the how the
applicant might know
who
to notify
i believe that information is available
through the national
pipeline mapping
npms whatever the whatever the acronym
stands for the national pipeline mapping
system
i believe that contact information is
available through them
for clarification then
i without this amendment
uh section 4 would require every town in
the state to
make national pipeline mapping system
geospace should be geospatial data
available
uh
in its town in its jurisdiction is that
correct
so this is a fairly significant change
then it is okay thank you and i would
defer to the pipeline operators sitting
behind me about how that
that information would be available to
applicants
representative cali pitts
just my convoluted mind thinking if i
own property
and i own
enough acreage that a
pipeline is beneath that property
and that property
due to the pipeline is
deemed
unbuildable
would then the pipeline
operator have to pay or buy an easement
on that property
because that
or is that taking of property by eminent
domain
because now my property cannot be built
on or subdivided or whatever well that's
going to be a private dispute between
the property owner and the
and the pipeline operator that would not
involve the municipality so i couldn't
answer that question
uh he's not the right person to answer
that question mr roberge from the
department of energy is here to answer
questions
i'll
ask him maybe if he could answer that
question
now
well just say yes or no i can answer
that question
okay thank you we won't call you up then
to answer that question
all right uh he doesn't he can't answer
the question so
maybe
the two gentlemen from
who
either mr perry from t c energy or
representative alexander could answer
the question
either one of you want to take a stab at
it
come up to the mic please
some circumstances similar to what you
mentioned you know that would be a
conversation that you know a company
could potentially have with a uh with a
with a property owner you know in
obtaining or purchasing or uh that piece
of property you know so and if you want
for further clarity on that i can i can
i'm happy to like i said i'll put you in
contact with the uh the uh
the people who who can answer those
questions on our land rep team because
you know they're they're going to give
it to you and and if people know me when
i say i'm going to do something i do it
so absolutely happy to do it
it's good it's good it's good dialogue
representative lewicki has a question
who do you want to direct actually i can
clarify on that if we would like
in the case of an existing pipeline
there already is an easement on the land
and it is in the deed for the land
a new pipeline would be a different
matter
okay thank you
thank you
all right uh
i think we've exhausted all the
questions for these gentlemen i
appreciate
mr graves being here from the municipal
association the only card i have left is
from
mr roberge from the department of energy
does anybody think they have a question
that they might like to ask him at this
point
seeing none i would like to ask him how
do you do it
well you can ask him that offline okay
all right seeing no further questions
and i'm going to close the public
hearing on house bill
1491 and i'm going to thank all members
of the committee for
another successful committee day we
heard a lot of
bills today we we had a lot of great
information exchange
and uh representative pimentel will now
give us the pollution thank you mr
chairman this was a very uh popular bill
uh there's no names on the blue sheet
and
the remote testifying one support and
two opposed
okay
sounds pretty uh pretty simple
okay everybody return your name tag to
the basket over by the door i will
remind everyone that on monday
the 14th there is a work subcommittee
work session on house bill 12
58 i believe it is the doe
department of energy
amendment that's at 10 a.m
there is no
committee meeting on tuesday the 15th
the house will be in session on the 16th
and the 17th
my current plan is to schedule our next
meeting on february 22nd and that will
be an executive sec
executive session on probably
half of the 20 remaining bills that we
have to deal with mr chair and then i
will try to schedule another executive
session on march the 1st
mr representative thomas
oh representative
when will we know which bills will be on
the earlier date versus the march date
as soon as uh representative thomas and
i figured that out
any any kind of an idea i mean it would
be good um next week
certainly before i notice it
in next wednesday's calendar so i'll
know by next wednesday the 16th
time
yes yes on wednesday the the 16th we're
meeting at one o'clock
uh at the doubletree in manchester we'll
meet in session until about six o'clock
and then the next day thursday we'll
come back at 9 30 and at 10 o'clock the
senate will join us and then and the
governor will issue his state of the
state address
and then the senate will leave and the
house will return to session and finish
all our early bills
representative oxenoump
yes i believe that they're going to
restrict it just to the house and the
senate this year because of the ongoing
coveted safety measures so there will be
no executive council there will be no
supreme court justices and i don't
believe there will be any other vips
there that's that's my understanding
okay
representative samsic uh mr chairman
just wanted to know did you receive all
the minority reports yet
i have not i have received only one and
i need the other minority reports uh
within the hour
see your submission
okay i haven't checked my email so i'm
not sure
you got mine i got yours
i didn't get yours yet but i haven't
checked my email okay
oh you haven't sent it
that could be why i haven't gotten it
that's what i did sometimes
yeah if you just write it up and give it
to the clerk they can submit it for you
definitely
you